Hello sweet freak bitches from space.
We are here. We're queer. Get
used to it. Remember that?
Oh yeah, we're queer. Get used to
it. Yeah. Alright. Jesus. Marsha,
about 10 of those problems.
That is,
what about all the people that
we're used to it, you know,
you don't have to get all fucking aggro.
I'm happy for you. Yeah. All right, good.
Um, I'm used to it. I'm used to it. Do
you really have to yell outside my window?
That was you walked by with a
million of your friends. You know,
if you live in San Francisco and
you're on that fucking parade route,
boy that that route is,
that's the one ours here and I'm
taking a nap that day. West Hollywood,
West Hollywood. One is, is on,
and it might be the bigger one.
West high would might be the
biggest gay spot in San Francisco.
Still has the reputation as the biggest
gay spot. But how can it fuck with,
how could it fuck with Hollywood?
There's more people here, man.
And that area is all gay.
There's no one area in San Francisco
where it's all gay. Yeah. You know,
there's areas in San Francisco where
there's a lot of gay folks that live,
but like West Hollywood is that one
stretch of Santa Monica Boulevard with all
the gay bars and all that. They just
own a neighborhood and that shit is,
it's on lock. It's like
mafia run. Absolutely. Yeah.
And if you go anywhere near there,
be prepared to suck a dick.
If someone's going to stuff one of
your mouth, it's going to happen.
There's only weight. One way to find
out. Let's go to be Joe Rogan questions.
Everything for the gate, gay
parades. How should we dress?
Definitely fucking do that. You
should go. You should go in like, uh,
some real BDSM like leather
shit with fucking change.
I don't want to question that.
Absolutely. But I feel like, um,
I dunno dude. I think, oh,
there are neighborhoods because isn't
wasn't what's the neighborhood in San
Francisco just handed something
and says move over in New York,
San Francisco and Los Angeles.
Columbus,
Ohio is now the nation's number
one gay city. Oh yeah, true. Yeah.
That's a good move. I mean, if you're gay
and you're on a budget, why fuck around?
Got a really nice spread and Columbus.
Yeah.
Why the fuck would you want
to pay la prices for a house?
Ellie prices for houses are goddamn
ridiculous. They are so stupid.
And the money in the city too that
you like, you don't like mine.
I read a rent a place or rent a house.
The House across from me just sold and
it sold for like eight 50 which I'm like,
wow, that's a lot of money, man. He'd
a hundred foot air tearing it down.
The tear down started yesterday and
they're going to put up some right.
But I'm saying that's the money that
like it. It puts into my mind where I go.
Jesus is like, not only do I not like as
an $850,000 house just out of my league,
my, that's a nice goal to get
through. They're like, no, we got it.
I'm gonna tear that shit down.
I'm going to build some shit I want.
So you spent eight 50 just to get
the lot of land. Fuck the house.
Now I'm going to spend money to build my
house. Well, you know what Arnold did?
He lived in the Palisades.
Yeah,
he bought the neighbor and then just
leveled his house and said, I want a yard.
Wow.
That's fucking another guy was like a $4
million house and just fucking leveled
it as wow,
that's fun place to kick my ball.
I mean he didn't even buy it.
Like move his mom in or something.
I need to grasp me.
Just leveled that bitch.
She didn't want to have family close
so no thank you. That just puts it to,
that takes us to another level.
Yeah, that's super boring.
I supposed to do commercials but at
this point it feels like we shouldn't do
commercials,
which just keep doing what we're doing.
But I have a certain amount of weekend I
guess I have to do Ron, you'll smiling.
I'll do. I'll just shoved them all
in tomorrow. Fuck commercials. No,
no commercials at all.
I'll shove them all in tomorrow and
tomorrow we got Matt full trunk.
That should be at a bad spot.
Full charges in the house.
And then on Wednesday we got
Kathleen Madigan old school all time.
Woman's great actually what her top 10
all time women comedian of all time.
And we always say like you shouldn't
do that. Shouldn't categorize uh,
men and women, but you do.
There you go. So tough shit.
There's an all time black guys is all
time white guys. All time drunk guys
all the time. Gay Guys. Who
on your all time drunk list?
Stan hope number one for sure.
Not even close, not even close.
Second a tells number two
when he was in his prime,
when it tells in his prime and he was
out there fucking hammer in it on a
regular,
he was hammered hard
and he's a brilliant, brilliant
comedian. On top of that he has,
he has some of the,
he has lines that are in our lexicon,
like my personal one,
you know what I mean?
Like he had a joke one time about
puppies and he was like, puppies pee,
you appease. And just, he always
said like silly shit. To this day.
I still say p you appease,
he did an album.
He recorded it at the comedy works
in Denver. Skanks for the memory,
one of my all time favorites and one of
the reasons why I want to record my next
special there. I mean I have to call
Wendy and ask her if she's cool with it.
My next comedy central special I want to
record in Denver. That's fucking right.
I want to record it in that
little spot because that club,
I don't think it seats even 300 people,
right? Is it about two 50 perhaps?
The downtown one is probably,
I would say it's probably Julie just
under 300 and then the other one is much
larger than the other ones. A little over
400 yeah. Yeah, but that one is perfect.
I went downtown,
it's like the perfect comedy club,
but it's like literally impossible
to get a better club. It's fantastic.
Everybody's locked in their seats.
The seats don't move all over the place.
Like you're in your spot.
That's the spot. Boom.
The tables welds as the fucking floor
and because of that they've gotten all
these people in and it's plenty
of room like to enjoy the show,
but everyone has their own little table.
It's a dub setup.
Wendy's a bad ass bitch. She's
bad motherfuckers. She's bad ass.
I call her a bitch with all due
respect stories. I love her.
She's very nice person.
She's one of the reasons why I moved
to Colorado in the first place.
She just had to run a club man. I knew
she had a real community. I was like,
if I'm going to live somewhere
outside of La and still do standup,
I need to go to a real community.
And the thing about Colorado is
they're really fucking around there.
There is a lot of people there
that are trying out shit.
There's a lot of people there that are,
you know, there's, there's good comedy.
They're like developing their own
good real comedy way before comedy,
I did comedy. That was my
number one choice for college.
Really? Denver University.
Yeah. It's so beautiful. I didn't get
in because you don't go floodings there.
It's crazy dude too.
Like roads washed away
completely or five people dead.
Hundreds missing.
Hundreds of people unaccounted for.
All my friends' basements are flooded,
but we saw some people on the Rogan board.
They posted photos and I saw some on CNN,
some other different places.
It's insane, man. It's really
crazy shit. Look at that.
Look at that. Look at that
giant chunk of street missing.
There was a video that they had online
that had this giant chunk of street just
wash away in front of these people and
their cars fell into it and they were
videoing like the waterfall smashing
into these cars. It was like what?
That used to be a street
just 10 minutes ago.
What was happening there
where I feel like, didn't we?
We knew floods were coming like
there was like, really? Yeah.
I thought there was like news
about these floods coming.
Do you remember that or no?
I don't know.
I don't pay attention until it's too late.
I'm like,
what if there's a typhoon in
Japan? Oh yeah, there's a typhoon.
It's going to hit Fukushima.
Oh,
they're already releasing radioactive
rain water into the ocean.
What they call low level radiation.
It's a low, would you go Japan,
I don't want to go anymore
because of that. And Yeah,
I think that that situation,
look,
obviously I'm an idiot and obviously I'm
paranoid so take those two things into
account,
but I'm worried about what
happens if while you're there
another earthquake kits.
Yeah. What if, you know what
if there's another earthquake,
it hits while you're there and they
get hit with another fucking tsunami.
You know, look that if it happened
once, just a couple of years ago,
it can happen again. Of course. And I
think that situation is very unstable.
Like they're coming up with all these
unique and novel ways to try to contain
the radioactive water.
Like for folks who don't understand it,
and I'm one of them,
but I'm going to reiterate some shit that
somebody said that doesn't understand
it. What they were basically saying
is you can't cool that shit down.
You have to continue to pump water on it
in order to try to cool that area down.
It's already melted through
its containment area.
So the radioactive waste is already
somehow or another in the ground.
So there's that.
And then there's,
they're pouring millions of
gallons of water on that thing.
Millions and millions and millions and
a lot of it is seeping right back into
the ocean.
So you're getting all this intense
radiation entering into the ocean at
unprecedented levels in mankind.
There's literally never been an a moment
in human kind where the earth had a
spill like this where
we radiated an ocean.
Most of that stuff that's on land as much
more containable like Chernobyl's more
containable. It's a fucked up place.
The plate. It's a dark, dark situation.
Chernobyl. But it's in Chernobyl. Yeah,
this shit is going to
go over the whole ocean.
It's getting out there and it's
floating and people are like, yeah man,
you're fucking, you know, you're being
a prophet of doom, you know, and you,
you don't even really know. And you're
talking all this crazy. Yes, you're right.
But I might be reading like really?
I'm not reading like any crazy,
you know,
a conspiracy new sites that
are giving me this information.
I'm reading like pretty much
all the mainstream sites.
No one is saying it's going to be okay.
I haven't heard anybody that
says relax about Fukushima.
Everything's going to be cool.
They don't know.
They're trying to build a giant hole in
the ground and they're going to stick
these cones all around it and then freeze
these cones to make a wall of ice so
they have to have all this radioactive
water contained in this fucking enormous,
several mile wide containment
area just to try just for water,
just radioactive water that
they're pouring on these
rods to try to cool it off.
Again,
I don't know exactly how it felt.
This has to affect everything
seafood from that area too. Right.
They've already shown a 3% rise in
the radiation of some fish. Really,
and that just happened,
I mean this week,
so that takes a while to get to us.
It might even not even get
to us for a year or so,
but a year or so they
might be telling you, hey,
it's probably not the best idea
to go in the water. That's real.
Like you're talking about a massive spill
that doesn't end and it's going to be
like that for hundreds of thousands of
years and I've had people like tweet me
about this and they're like,
wow,
it's all diluted and you have to realize
how big the ocean is and you're totally
right. Absolutely. It's pro, I'm
probably looking at it wrong.
I'm probably being an alarmist,
but it's never going to stop leaking.
Do you get that?
It's never going to stop.
What might not be a
horrific catastrophe today?
Could easily be one 50 years from now
if they can ever never get it to stop.
Like part of the reason why people aren't
freaking out is because we always have
this optimism about like
human ingenuity is said,
we're going to figure out a way,
right?
We're going to figure out a
way we got to figure out a way.
We're not going to figure
out a way with that. Okay.
The nuclear thing is a weird thing.
It's weird thing because it does work
most of the time and everybody wants to
stress that like, listen, you're
being an alarmist about nuclear power.
It does work most of the time,
but people have only
been alive for how long?
What is the agreement is at a hundred
thousand years or something like that.
Let's say a million in this form,
right?
Let's say we've been around a million
years in the last 100 we've made three
spots where you can never go again.
As long as they've been
human beings alive.
That's how long into the
future it's likely that area
is going to be irradiated.
What are the three Chernobyl
for my island and then this one,
Fukushima. Those are, those
are, those three spots are gone.
We don't own those spots anymore.
The universe owns those spots. Yeah,
physics on those spots.
The insanity of atomic power own those
spots and it's just very weird situation
where nobody wants to admit that.
That's a striking number three in the
60 plus years that it's been active,
three places are useless. What is,
what's a thousand years from now?
You mean just take the time and do the
math? You can't stop it. You, Mike,
unless you come up with some insane new
technology that figures out a way to
contain that radiation,
you're always going to deal
with a really bizarre problem.
A problem in that if you use it,
you make the area around
you unsafe for life forever,
for a hundred thousand years mean
what does a hundred thousand years,
you can't even wrap your head around that.
I know.
There was no civilization a hundred
thousand years ago and to Zilch, none.
Nothing. Everybody agrees. Even Graham
Hancock agrees. All the, the, the,
the craziest theorists about
backdating civilization,
they all go a hundred
thousand years ago. Oh, Jesus.
We were fucking throwing spears,
you know,
wooden sticks that we
sharpened at the end.
We probably didn't know
how to use fire yet.
Imagined life here a
hundred years ago too.
There was no language a
hundred thousand years ago.
They think language is 40,000 years
old. Really? Yeah. It was all just,
just glancing points and shit and showing
by example and screaming to be some
really successful comics.
I,
yeah, it would be like the best
time ever for a lot of comics.
No words don't even need the word of
that. Um, it's, it's hard to believe
that we're willing to gamble,
that we're going to fix that.
Do you ever read about how many,
I was fascinated by how
many languages go extinct.
Like every year there's languages that,
you know,
there's obviously like the huge languages
that millions and even billions of
people speak,
but then every year there are languages
that they're trying to preserve by
continuing to speak them.
And you know,
people learn language just to have it
like an endangered species and then it
just goes away.
Yeah. I saw an article recently on the
guy who was like the last guy to know this
language really? And they, yeah,
they had studied this dude and he had
tried to communicate it with them and then
he fucking died. Yeah. That's,
and that's what happened,
ms with a lot of the native cultures
or native American tribes that had a
specific language and they're like, they
passed along, passed along, and then,
you know, it becomes like not important
or not cool to pass the language.
Like it's not useful.
And then it's fewer and fewer people
speak it like they found languages.
I think even in South
America of like Inter,
like in the jungles that they thought like
this group and language had, you know,
gone whatever extinct forever and
found that there is still living in the
jungles.
Is
it, you know, I don't know anything
but English, but you know Spanish,
he speaks Spanish. Yeah. It's
pretty well the, Oh, I've seen you talk to
people. Yeah. Pretty. Pretty fluid. Yeah.
Especially to me that
doesn't speak anything.
So how much different are
those two as a language?
Like you have to think differently.
Right? That's what the,
that's the reason why like a lot of people
who are from another country and make
the same mistakes over and over again,
whether it's German people,
Brazilian people, a lot of them
make the same kind of mistakes.
It's because the whole structure of
sentences is different. It's true. Yeah.
Like they're used like in Spanish
you say something like, you know,
you say chocolate milk in English and
there you would say milk of chocolate.
Right. That's how you say
that. [inaudible]. So, um, you
say, but so like if you're,
if you're trying to literal translations
sometimes the way that you would say it,
you have to reconstruct it but it,
it comes easier to you if
you're hearing it all the time.
Like I used to hear Spanish
every day. I mean, you know,
for the first 18 years of my life
because that's what my mom spoke.
So it becomes you,
you realize like the way to say
that it's automated to does it ever,
does it ever fuck with your English?
Did it fuck with your English as a kid?
Like did you like mix up the wrong,
like accidentally use like a Spanish
word for it or accidentally say something
in a way that you would say English,
but he said it in Spanish.
I think that came more when I was
learning to speak more. Like for the,
for the longest time my mom spoke Spanish
to us and we just spoke English to her.
It was always a deadline.
And she spoke,
I mean she said everything in Spanish
and we were applied completely in English
and she completely understood that.
So we completely understood her but are
speaking Spanish wasn't as good and her
speaking English wasn't as good.
But then she started with my parents
sent me to spend my summers in Peru and
then that's when it greatly like,
cause you already understand so much
because you were exposed to it and then
you're forced to speak it.
But when you're forced to speak it
to everybody it gets way better.
What did you do in Peru?
I would go to school like I would just,
cause our summers are there
winners. So My, my uh,
I have a ton of cousins and stuff.
I would say with one aunt and an ankle,
I came to speak English.
Right. And uncle, I'll go look.
And they had three boys that
were like my age basically.
So I would go there, go to school and
just fuck around. I mean we would just,
you know, you're just 12, 13, 14 years
old, just, you know, living in Lima.
And then they would come to the United
States one by one for their summers to
get better at English. Wow. Yeah.
So we'd take turns at each others they
say that's one of the best ways to
improve your mind. Really. Yeah.
The learning other languages and speaking
in other languages. And then also, um,
when you start to dream in light in
those languages that yeah, that happens.
Yeah, that happened when
I was in college. I just,
I went to spend a semester in Spain
and at that point I had already,
I already spoke pretty pretty well and
then I started to do like college term
papers in Spanish.
You know where you're writing,
write 20 page papers for a class on
comparative economics and Spanish,
Jesus Christ son.
And then at that point,
I mean my Spanish now is not nearly as
good as it was like the year after I left
Spain or that I was there and that whole
year after, because it was other level,
I dream I was dreaming in Spanish.
It was my first thoughts came to
me in Spanish, you know, like,
cause it was just so much and
it's such a high level every day.
How long do you think it would take
you if you were immersed in the Spanish
culture to start speaking
like that again? I think, um,
I think a couple years would
be, I would be, I mean,
I could go and I speak to people now in
Spanish and they asked me what country
I'm from so they get confused.
Say it confuses this weird motherfucker.
Here's the weirdest thing,
and I know it's funny,
like if people who speak Spanish
know exactly what I'm talking about,
I don't speak Spanish. I speak Spanish
like a South American and you would,
you would know that it's probably
from Colombia or Peru, that area,
because there's very specific little
accent details. Just like here,
when someone from New York, from
Boston, from Texas, you know, you, you,
you pick up, it was someone
from Maryland, you know,
someone even like specifically
Baltimore has a very specific accent.
So when you speak Spanish,
it's the same deal, right?
You pick up on these little details and
people who are native Spanish speakers,
we'll go, oh, are you from
Argentina to me all the time,
even though I have nothing
of an Argentine accent,
but they do it because
I look like I could,
I'm more from Argentina than I am from
Peru. Isn't that interesting? So they're,
they're associating what they see and
not what they hear. Well, Argentina is a,
more like Spain was more,
was more like Mexico. Well,
like look,
like features wise,
there's a way bigger native
Indian population in Peru,
Peru weigh more and there's a,
there's a white like
Caucasian population too.
It's just a great minority in Argentina.
It's the opposite.
Did a lot of Nazis go down there and when
the fan fuck yeah, yeah, yeah. Did Right.
Yeah. They theirs and the most
famous of all extractions, um,
W it's the story of the
House on [inaudible] street
is about, like I say that,
yeah.
The Eichmann uh,
oh yeah.
I,
and moved to when a scientists and he
was living in a house and he had his
family there. Right. His wife, his kids.
One of his kids told somebody
in school about like a,
as a secret, told the girl he was
dating about the truth of his family.
Oh No.
The girl ratted him out
and what Israel did,
which is like considered unacceptable
when you talk about the way that countries
interact with Gordon international
standards and you know,
treaties and the way that we all have
kind of a diplomatic process that we go
about. His Day came in and Jason
Bourne style took that motherfucker,
kidnapped him, flew him back to
Israel and was like, we got this guy.
And they were like, wow, like
that kind of Shit, you know,
instead of trying to go about, hey,
we want to go for a whole extradition,
they came in, snagged him,
brought him back. Yeah. The,
the Israelis don't play. Fuck no, no,
they don't play when it
comes to that shit either.
Some girl at a,
I mean it's kind of a fucked up story,
but some girl was a photographer
and she had gone to uh,
the West Bank and she took some
photographs and when she was going through
Israeli customs, some of the photographs
were like of spray paint graffiti.
And one of them said like,
fuck the Jews who shit.
So the dude puts her laptop down the
ground, he goes, I'll be right back.
He takes a gun, comes back and
shoots the fucking laptop. Wow.
Shot Laptop and gave it back to
her, the bullet hole in it. Wow.
And she was like, what the fuck? I'm
a photographer. I saw this. I took,
it's taking pictures of chaos.
You know, she's a Jew by the way.
She's a Jew. Yes. She was a Jew. Jesus.
They don't fucking play man. Fuck the
Jews. Okay, well there's nothing clearly.
There's no explaining it either. Like now
here's the thing like that. Like, Nah,
they just took it over. Doom, doom, doom.
That's like a, the guy handed it to her.
Did you see that guy do that
online? But the dad, what did he do?
His daughter has nothing to do
with like racism or anything,
but his daughter was complaining about
her parents on Facebook and like fucking
these chores.
They think I'm like,
are their slave like telling me
I have to do all these chores?
So the guy is like, I've been, she
had her, her Facebook page locked.
So like her family couldn't see it.
Well her dad's like a
software guy and he was like,
you forgot like what I do for a living.
Right. He made a video. He's like,
so I saw what you said.
So what you think we mistreat you?
You're a slave in this house.
Okay, well here's your laptop.
I just spent a few hundred dollars
upgrading it and he puts on the ground.
He just, he empties like a 45
into it. Oh my God. He's like,
I'm gonna put this on your Facebook page
so all your friends can see this shit.
Like extreme. Yeah. But he was like,
daddy don't play Holy Shit.
He shot it and no,
he just shot it in the videos that she
would see it on her Facebook page. Oh,
like her laptop when she got
home from school. I got confused.
I thought he was doing it in front of her.
No, no, no, no, no, no. He did it like,
like as a, you know, a
message to her that she did.
So she would go online later
and see that on her own.
That on her own Facebook page.
Yeah. This is, yeah. Yeah.
Oh, you know what, man, first of all,
I don't think this guy understands.
He's putting his daughter
out there like that. Naming
her. It's humiliating. It's,
it's a douchey thing to do. It's,
you're raising a human being.
You don't do that in front of the
whole fucking world by shaming them.
Humiliation has a pretty profound effect.
Does
man, and it's intense and so unnecessary.
The guy's a father, you know,
that said, it's pretty funny.
I mean, I don't recommend it,
but if you do it, I'll watch the video.
Uh, it's probably as a shithead though.
He's a shithead. Um, but I imagine
that she stopped posting. She's like,
might not even know he's a shithead,
you know, because part of raising a kid,
I don't want to sound like Doctor Oz,
but part of raising a kid is
shooting the laptop.
One, two, three, four, five,
six. Oh yeah. After that
comment you made about your mom,
your mom told me to be sure I
put one in there for her. So
dance from her fucked up. Shit.
That's rednecks with guns.
No ma'am. All right. Wow.
Disturbing. That guy's a knucklehead.
That guy's a serious knucklehead.
He might not even know he's a knucklehead.
People think that when you're raising
a child that you're supposed to,
you know that somehow or another,
their development isn't your
responsibility. You know,
they just want you to grow up on your own.
They don't want to sort of guide you
along the way and explain in a, in a nice,
healthy way. Yeah, why what
you're doing is incorrect.
And here's where we're really coming
from. You know, and people just work.
They work and they leave their kids
alone and then when they get home,
they're tired.
They stick them in front of the TV and
then they wonder why this girl is ranting
and raving and saying stupid shit.
A lot of the reason why kids say stupid
shit is just because they're getting
older.
They're getting a mind of their own.
They think they got it all
figured out yet or now. But Bob,
a lot of it is also because they're being
raised by morons that shoot computers
and what effect is the computer shooting?
Really going to have long guy's a moron.
Moron. Move. She's going to have a gun.
You know, like she's going to think that
you could, you could just shoot laptop.
She might shoot him. Man,
that guy's a dick. That's,
that's a dick move to not just do that,
to do that to dick move to put
it on her fucking Facebook.
That's a super dick move.
Yeah.
Or she might learn that like the way to
handle like somebody's upsetting you is
to shoot their shit to
my daddy told me not to take no guff.
My Daddy told me how to get back
on a mother fucker. A 45 yeah,
I'll shoot your fucking football bap, bap,
Bap out light shit up. And you're like,
wow, you were kind of the wrong chick
from me. Those wild redneck pitches.
It was West Virginia girl.
You see that the wild. That's
right. You gave me that.
My favorite part of that whole movie
is a like one of the, I don't know,
one of the fucking absolute disasters
of that family is like this right here.
She's like,
I got these Xanax gone for like six
bucks a piece roll down the street.
So for eight bucks a piece, a little
boot scoot and boogie right there.
Like make some money like this.
You're selling it for $2 more.
Well that's all you can
cash today. That's how we do
it. We got 16 bucks now. Bit.
Yeah, there's not much,
there's not much room there.
That's just incredible.
Plus if you go to jail,
like all your profits are going to get
eaten up by an attorney of court fees.
You gotta be able to work. But they
never had a word cause it never works.
Which is hilarious. Best part. Yeah.
When they talked to the politician,
if you the w the wild and
wonderful whites of West Virginia,
I believe Johnny Knoxville,
um,
directed it or producer or something
along spam is a company I think produced
that movie. Yeah. And he just was
embedded who was embedded in their,
their lifestyle.
And you've got a chance to see them like
for real legit 100% where they are and
they're awesome. And people
looked at it so depressing. No,
you can decide it's suppressing. Well,
you can decide. It's like a human zoo.
That's awesome. Yeah.
It's like there's a point,
you're watching that movie and you go,
there's no way it can contain.
Like there's no way. There's another
character after this and just family.
And that's about 10 minutes in
and they just,
and then like an hour and you're like,
you've gotta be shitting me right now.
And the next guy, and then I shot
him in this chest and you're like,
what the fuck? How about that one
dude who had escaped the state?
He moved up to Minnesota.
He has family sitting there.
They're all sitting around drinking. Go,
man, they're just too fucking crazy. Yeah.
He had to fucking crazy. He does
not belong. Like that's, that's,
that's good that he left.
He's the guy with a job and a family.
Like he looked at all of our sponsors,
this whole, in that family, they're like,
he's a fucking asshole because he
got his shit together and left. Yeah.
He's a fucking lit. He, um,
he won't sell out. Yeah.
You ain't go out and work for your money.
But he had a story to, it was, he had
done at least one or two crazy things,
I think. Right. Like you did at
least one crazy shit. Yeah. Yeah.
If you don't believe that this movie is
[inaudible] think we're exaggerating,
you just kind of hear this
woman Bobby sue talk. Oh.
If you see,
if you can find Bobby sue
from wild and wonderful west,
it's Bobby sue. Right?
Wasn't there Bob Sue Bob to,
my name's sue Bob. I
call him. I'm the sacs.
He might in the family
and she's being serious.
They're all kind of sexy and it
kind of a crazy way. A little bit.
It probably be the one you'd
want a little Mug, a moonshine.
If those are your options.
I think you wouldn't do if you were
living up there and that was your life and
you're selling pills for two bucks over
for a living and the Supai Blah wants to
throw down you like, oh, on,
let me put the possum away.
Uh,
yeah,
they're fucking epic disasters and no,
I don't wish they were like this.
Absolutely.
I wished that they were a really nice
people who are normal. Oh, that's,
that's not the one.
There it is.
I take those out
and that's what made the band Kansas.
Somebody I brought it home nice.
15 to $2,000 a night.
And uh,
I've always been effect as well in the
family violence that Tom has thousands of
paper.
Ooh,
you gotta do what you gotta do.
If you're trapped in West Virginia and
you're on a horse and there's no way out,
you got to do what you gotta do. A
Bose be the is. What about Fab Jesus?
She looked like a female version of
whirlpool champion. Johnny Archer.
Is he the sexiest one in pool? Yes. Yeah.
And she's the sexiest one in the family.
Yeah. Don't hate it. Just
is what it is, man. Yeah.
[inaudible] always been the sax.
You're just wanting,
her voice is like, it's,
it's makes you wonder if life is real
because it makes you wonder if like when
you see that or you see a
grizzly man or yeah, any of this.
It makes you wonder, man,
that club also lets you know,
it makes you wonder if life can affect
your voice. You know what I mean? Like,
yeah. But I mean like that has,
imagine the impact that's had.
Her voice was not always like that. No, it
couldn't have been right. No Way. No Way.
Man. That is a long, that's
a lot of sleepless nights.
That's a lot of being up till 5:00 AM.
That's,
that's two middle like Tupac pill.
Just that'd be hard living hard
living about, don't be scared.
Don't be scared.
Pussy don't act like you don't think
I'm San one sounds like a pussy.
And then there's the mom who
runs everything that mom has,
bad ass mag. It's her. She's the
one dealing, what was her name?
Fuck,
I don't remember man.
I don't remember saying that was so
God damn good movie and yeah, I agree.
It's depressing but it is. It's
out there. It is what it is.
I always talk about Stevie. You saw
Stevie, Stevie, them documentary? No.
What's that? It's super, it's
hilarious. But it's also like there's,
people are like, this is a
bummer. I'm like, it's still
hysterical. It's an about,
it follows this Guy Stevie
who the filmmaker actually
was like a big brother to
him and like the big brother program or
something and it goes back and revisit
him like 20 years later and he is like,
he belongs in the whites, West
Virginia family. You know,
he's one of those guys and like he gets,
it's,
he's fucking retarded. I mean there's no
other like, do you have a Stevie clip?
This is the only thing that I've
came up with Stevie. Oh really?
That's definitely, this is not acting.
You checking them out of real? No, no, no.
It's the same guy that made hoop dreams.
Did you ever see hoop dreams?
It's a really good document either.
It's a really good documentary. Yeah,
I heard it was really good. Fantastic. So
many films and I never get too, man. Yeah.
Oh, me too. You have the time.
I'm like Mary doses to them
and then I don't really even,
there's so many out there that is so
good. This it, this. Let's see. Very good.
Solitary, not involved with
other people a whole lot.
I
Stevie neglected. That's
kind of the, the ammo.
There's somebody who molests kids
areas.
You've got to look at it really cold
started looking on the human individuals
and while, yeah, this, he's
really not that bad guy. Well,
why don't you look at the victim.
The victim is wasn't that bad
of a person either. I mean,
you've given him chances in the past
and now he's got himself in a load of
trouble and you give them another chance.
That guy's a smooth talker.
Yeah.
So do you think Steve's innocent? No.
Cause he said, he told me what he did do,
but I mean,
he's going to,
he's already sitting up with that
kept being added. Sister's daughter.
His niece.
Yeah. Oh Jesus, they might call you
as a witness if this goes to trial.
You know,
this isn't the funniest click actually
floodings in Japan.
The thing when I talk about the funny
stuff in this movie before you think I'm
insane, it's because of like
the little things like you know,
before it all goes down like he's,
he's like,
they call me snake cause I
ain't afraid of them. You know,
they always call me snake glasses.
Yeah.
Stevie and you're like no one will
know everything went down. You know,
before it gets like create like before
he gets arrested and stuff and they're
just
following him around and
like is that him on the left
wearing a tie dye shirt? Yes. Yes.
And that's the kind of the Shit I'm
saying that you laugh at like you just,
so that's where he's over here.
Go ahead and get it here
while your sister's discount.
He's just a fucking milk and we didn't
get it. Idiot. You know, I don't all,
oh man. Who the fuck would leave that guy
alone with your kid? Yeah, it's a great,
great question. What a piece
of shit. Piece of shit.
Pieces of shit that molest
kids, man. That's it.
That's us real special piece of
shit. It's like, yeah, oh yeah,
that's the recidivism rate is so high.
The amount of fucked up in this you have
to have going on to do that is so high.
That's a really bad one.
That's when it's really hard to forgive.
And that's that too is like, um,
you know, even when they, um,
given to like
acknowledging what they did wrong.
If you give them the space to justify it,
they will.
Did you hear this Dawkins quote,
Dawkins gotten a lot of trouble for
talking about mild pedophilia? No,
she was really weird, man.
What he's saying. Um, hold on,
I'll find it for you. Um, he, uh, he said
that there's, if as long as it's not,
it's just a mild touching
up that your psychology,
um, uh, would, uh, would erase it here.
Let me remark. Provokes
outrage. Yeah. He's like,
your mind would protect you from it as
long as it was just mild touching up.
You know, it's really weird. The,
the, the quote is really weird.
He says that he experienced mild
pedophilia in English school when he was a
child in the 1950s referring to his early
days at boarding school in Salisbury.
He recalled how one of the unnamed
masters pulled me on his knee and put his
hand inside my shorts.
He said other children in his school
peer group had been molested by the same
teacher,
but concluded.
I didn't think he did any of
us lasting harm. I'm very,
I'm very conscious that you can't
condemn people of an earlier era by the
standards of ours.
Just as we don't look back at the 18th
and 19th centuries and condemn people for
racism and the same way we would
condemn a modern person for racism.
I look back a few decades into my
childhood and I see things like canning,
like mild pedophilia and can't find it
in me to condemn it by the same standards
as I or anyone would today.
He said, that's interesting.
I think that's kind of a it,
you know,
it's very brave of him to say
because it's very, it's very, uh,
controversial obviously. Yeah. I mean,
I don't totally disagree with him as far
as holding people to different eras of
different standards.
Yes.
I don't think that he should be the one
necessarily to comment on how that might
have affected some of his classmates
though. Right. When he says like,
I don't think any of us were really,
um, too effected by that. I mean,
you don't know that some of those guys
might have been completely traumatized,
you know,
quite honestly some people would say
that he's been damaged by and he just
doesn't realize it.
Absolutely. That, you know,
maybe that would make sense for why,
you know,
he's gotten into some, some of the
situations that he's gotten into.
Some of the things that he said in the
past that had been fairly controversial.
Sure. Maybe it was about this,
um, you know, but anyhow,
but people think it's like super
irresponsible. That's the, the main rub.
Anybody to go out there and say,
oh,
it's not that big a deal for a little
mild pedophilia projecting. Well, yeah.
And not, well, not only that,
but it also could almost encourage mild
pedophilia as being nothing of course.
And then, you know, you could go back
to like what I was saying, where he,
the guy that is doing this then
justify, he's like, I'm not really like,
it's so minor. I'm just,
you know, right now,
clearly he's saying that this is
a different era than he's calm.
He's talking about a different era and
that we can't judge the people of that
era today.
But he's still talking about it as if
there's like a mechanism to protect you
right from this kind of, I'm going to
sneeze. Sorry. Okay. I felt a code.
That's you man that was, you know,
happen clean my nose hairs out. Yeah.
I got a little nose hair
trimmer and sometimes they
get some strays up there and
you just can't resist those sneezes
when they're coming. They're, oh yeah.
Do you get, you get that from like, no,
but when I look at light it'll make me
sneeze. What I'm saying. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I knew it was coming and I just stare at
the light percentage of the population
does that really? And like, it's
called a light induced. Amazing. Yeah.
Oh, that's interesting. So like
I'm one of those two where like,
and I've told people like that
about it and like, and they're like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And they have no like,
you have never done that.
Never heard of that.
Because if I would be outside I would
just be sneezing all like crazy, you know?
But look it up. Like look up like sunlight
induced or lightened, do sneezing.
You'll see that like it's a,
you're like that too. Yeah. Yeah.
If you walk out of like a movie theater,
you got off shit.
And like just if I go crate, yeah.
Every time. So what people are saying,
people were really pissed
at him and this guy,
his name's Peter Wad is director of
the child protection and then of the
National Society for the
prevention of cruelty to children.
He said Dawkins remarks were a terrible
slight on those who have been abused and
suffer the effects for decades.
Mr Docken seems to think that because
a crime was committed a long time ago,
we should judge it in a different way.
Watts said,
we know that victims of sexual
abuse suffer the same effects,
whether it was 50 years ago or
today. Yeah. He's uh, probably,
you know, correct. I mean, the,
the thing that you have to examine is
like Dawkins statement and you have to
think, you consider it case
by case. So I don't mean,
I don't mean pedophilia case by case.
I mean like the whole idea about judging
people based on an era like, you know,
to, to a degree you kind of
go, well, in a certain era,
certain certain point of
views we're allowed, you know?
But I don't know that that
really applies to pedophilia.
Yeah. It doesn't, it seems like that's
always been a really dark thing to do.
But what's really fucked up is when
you go way back to like the classics.
Like if you go back to you, you
know, like Socrates was gay,
there was a lot of guys back
then that were not just gay,
but took on young boys is letters.
Right.
That was a very common amongst the
Samurai Samurai took on young boys,
his lovers. That applies
to what he's saying. Right.
Your examples are our people in now
this happens to be much long time ago,
but it's, well it's very,
it's, it's, you know,
it's very different when a person
who's alive today in the context of our
society right now speaks about pedophilia
as if it's not that big a deal when it
happened to him.
Yeah.
And someone talking about like
almost an imperceptible difference.
I mean not,
not imperceptible,
but inconceivable difference between
the way the culture of Japan in the 12th
century was and the culture of
the United States and you know,
2013 I mean they're not even the
same planet. Right. It's so hard to,
you're dealing with a Japanese,
they have a completely different language,
different culture. And there,
this is a long, long, long, long,
long fucking time ago
when people couldn't even,
it took a long time to get anywhere,
get by boat or by horse.
But for the most part people fucking
stood still and they developed their own
culture sort of a way from
the rest of the world.
And it's one of the more fascinating
aspects about it. But when you look back,
what is the common theme? The common
theme in almost all these cultures,
gay sex,
gay sex and pedophilia.
Like they did it throughout
Rome, throughout the Greeks, the,
all the Spartans were gay.
Samurais like there was so much gay sex,
like our idea of what?
Like sex is in 2013 like we think that,
oh,
back then you know if he
got locked up in prison,
you had a a dude like no big deal. No, no.
They were banging each other and
they were banging everybody. Yeah.
I want to know when people like settle
down and stop just fucking guys. Oh,
there was no, there was no judgment
about that, of that was like, hey man,
dicks hard. You've got
an asshole. Let's do it.
What's almost like it was too hard to
get laid back then. Yeah. You know,
and like sometimes you just
had to do what you had to do.
I got to imagine that if
you go back far enough,
a lot of sexual behavior went unchecked.
It was just,
you were just an acting on it and
went into whatever sex act you wanted,
desired that like you're,
you're fucking monkey brain was dictating
and you didn't really think about how,
you know, like the way that
you're a culture looked upon it.
People just did stuff. Right. And
then that was it. There was no,
I'm going to talk to somebody
about you made me uncomfortable.
Like you just did whatever you
wanted to do and there's no,
there's no HR back then that way,
like unchecked civilization like
that clearly is a different form of
civilization. It's different world.
It's wild, wild west type shit. Oh yeah.
To the fucking umpteenth power though
when you talk about hundreds of years ago.
Oh yeah. Well when you get
really, um, Viking Shit and, or,
or the all of ancient Europe.
Yeah.
If you ever heard a lady battery ever
heard of this fucking evil bitch and
Elisabeth Bathory, she was a, a,
a royalty and a 1560 in Hungarian
Hungary and this bitch killed like,
they don't even know how many women
she started getting. As she got older,
she started killing younger women.
She didn't want them around. Yeah,
I'm pretty sure she would
cut them up and torture them.
Kill and she killed hundreds of them.
Hundreds pretty bitch. And they
didn't even kill her when it was over.
They convicted her and put
her in like a room for life.
They just locked her in
this room. Hungarian. Yeah.
Well she was royalty. Yeah.
So because of the fact that
she was royalty, they just
decided not to kill her.
Yeah. The, the, the level of
brutality when you go back for it,
like you have ever read about
of Lod the impaler. Yes.
I mean he would impale enemies and
people in his camp who didn't like who he
heard spoke against him and to impale
them and he would do it and sometimes when
you were impaled, you know, they could,
it could go right through a vital
artery or Oregon and you'll die.
But there's a lot of times
when you can get impaled.
It can literally miss every vital
artery in Oregon and you bleed out,
impaled just in the sun for a day.
Holy Shit.
With,
with a fucking wooden rod up through
your ass hole going through your body and
coming out like your shoulder or
mouth and you're just bleeding.
I mean it's a pretty gruesome way to go.
Oh my God.
There was something about a bad set.
Hmm. There was, I think it was in Persia.
A stake in Persia. Hold on. Did
you see this picture of what story?
There's a story about
these, uh, people, uh,
back in the Roman days where there was
like miles of bodies on steaks to warn
people as they approached.
So as these people approached,
I need to find the exact story,
but as these people approached a,
I guess it would, there was a
pro, they were approaching Persia.
They had miles of bodies
on steaks to let you know,
like you're coming here and trying to
fuck with us cause this is what we're
going to do to you.
Yeah.
And you'd get that stanch about five
miles before you saw it. You know,
he'd be like, what is that smell man?
But just the idea that I was around,
people would do that,
that they would just run rows
and rows and rows of bodies.
Do you think that that the only reason
that doesn't go on today is because
there's like that morally checking
thing or because that would suggest that
there's like way more either acceptance
of that behavior or there's just like,
er, like crazier sociopath just
running shit all the time, you know?
Well, I think that's a probably are
today. I think it's, it's, it's way they,
they're way better at like hiding the
more fucked up things that people do today
that would be like way out
in the open. Yeah. You know,
like it's this situation that's going
on right now in Syria where everybody's
saying that this is the
most important thing,
that we have to step up and we have to
go and we have to attack Syria because
Syria has done this thing and,
and these,
these people have have died and
these innocence or being poisoned.
There's no mention whatsoever
in the mainstream news of
the irony of the guy who
is the head of the United States military.
The commander in chief talking
about innocent people dying, right?
I mean it's Kinda crazy, right? Oh yeah.
It's like this idea that there's a certain
amount of innocent people that must
die and those are okay.
Right?
But when innocent people
die and this guy did it,
then it's really bad. And especially
the way he did it. Right. You know,
the way he did it with poison and
we just, we can't take that. That's,
we were drawing along. We're gonna have
to kill some more people because of that.
Right,
right.
And innocent people will die because
we have to protect innocent people.
So we have to go in there.
This guy killed.
Innocent people will probably kill way
more innocent people than a flower if we
went in there. If the army,
the United States army when it,
unless Siri just said fuck this,
and they laid down their guns and went
face down and put their hands behind
their heads, immediately someone's
going to die. People are going to die.
It's crazy.
It's like the idea behind it.
It's like one of the weirdest
side shows ever. Well, the,
the perspective you're talking about is,
is pretty much purposely kept out of our
u s kind of mainstream news discussion
allowed photograph coffins.
Like that was something that was passed
during the Bush administration. Yeah.
You couldn't take photos
of coffin because yeah,
sure that would have an impact
but how we can kill people,
but all I'm saying is
that it's okay to do that,
but the reality of it should never get
back home cause he could weaken morale.
Yeah. Like Woo, you're, you're,
you're stomping information.
Like information is critical for people
to understand the actual parameters of
the situation they're involved in. And
if you change that information a change,
how much of that information gets out,
you greatly alter.
If you can't see evidence of it, they're
not seeing bodies, they're not seeing,
they're not seeing the damage. You're not
focusing on the bad stuff. You're not,
you're not being accurate.
Of course,
you're giving a really fucked up
version of what you're talking about.
Governments are good at that,
but that should be illegal.
That should be highly illegal.
Like to do that to say to someone,
you can't take a photograph of something
that's actually happening because the,
that idea behind it, the weakening
of morale, like that's crazy.
Morale only weekends when it's
supposed to be weakened. Okay.
If we were off their
fighting werewolves and,
and bodies were coming back like that,
we would salute them and
praise them and their, their,
their quest to save the human race from
the werewolves that they died. No, Billy,
we would celebrate them. We would fucking
have parades for them, had no belief,
celebrate them. But that's not
what we're doing. We're hiding.
We're hiding the photos.
We don't show them to anybody
because the whole thing is chaos.
And if you really boil it down is it
wasn't worth it that your child died to
promote this agenda. No,
it's not. It's not. It's not,
that's not the only way it could
have been done. That's crazy to say.
It's the only way it could have
been done is absolute bananas. Yeah.
To stay healthy. A diplomatic strategy
works out. I mean, I hope so too.
But I mean I can't believe that we're
still committed to fucking years and years
of war in 2013 and it just doesn't
make any sense anymore. I know, I know.
It's interesting too if
you like cause you really,
it didn't really is up to you to figure
out stories. It you have to like,
it's interesting to go to different
sites to see how they present the story,
the same story. Oh you know, like you go,
you read CNN and then you read like if
you go to g drudge to see how they report
it and you go to like
BBC, Guardian, Al Jazeera,
you're getting the same story
reported in six different ways. Yeah.
And you got to kind of decipher
if that you've got, you have to,
you have to pick up on the fact and
know that everybody has a bias even when
they don't have a bias. You know,
there's built in bias to every angle,
every story.
Oh yeah.
You have to be able to break that down
to whatever degree because you have your
own bias that wants to lean a certain way
and you go, this is the story. I'm, well,
I'm going to run with the one that day
this person reported and that's a big one.
Whenever you've got anyone that's
pushing a left wing or white wing agenda,
whenever you started hearing about
what the Democrats want to do is give
everybody this bit and take all your
hard earned money and like you like, Oh,
you're not even being honest here.
You're just putting it on this puppet
show and you're probably invested in
winning this puppet show or in the Megan
works puppet show. Very convincing.
You got lobbyists that are counting on
you to get me to believe your perspective
on this right now. For sure.
They're filling up your
pockets, man. Yeah, whatever.
Addictiveness way to run a government.
The idea that that's how we run it.
I know all this money and influence.
They're all always,
always only thinking about their
next election. Don't worry,
we're thinking of you. Yeah. I'm
not thanking him. All this money.
All these people that have this money,
the got me into this position.
I don't think about them. I think
about people, I don't know who hate me.
That's what I'm concerned with. His
fucking, his favorability rating.
It's like Bush, like now
it's like, is that that low
now? That's pretty low. Yeah.
Let's find out. What's what Obama's
Obama's approval rating. Yeah.
Let's, uh, what was the
worst? The worst? Yeah,
I bet the worst was probably,
I'm going to,
I'm going to guess it was something
like 80 years ago and then Bush would be
like second. That's my prediction.
First of all, how crazy is it?
There's something called the
approval rating for the president.
Okay.
Here it is.
47% of likely US voters approve
of Obama's job performance.
Okay. I mean, the 52% disapprove. Okay.
That's not horrific. It's definitely, um,
it's definitely lower than it's been.
Right. Well, listen to this though.
82% of the Democrats like the job,
the president's doing
85% of the Republicans and 50%
57% of the voters not affiliated,
disapprove. Okay. Come on man. You
look on the craft side of that is how,
how silly could you be to say,
I think he's doing a great job.
Number one is Obama,
number two is number one
is number one is Bush.
That's the lowest approval rating.
Ever. See, lowest approval ratings.
His lowest approval was 25 Bush.
And what's the next lowest?
Do you remember when Bush's
approval ratings were fucking high?
Like right after September
11th really high.
You weren't even allowed to make fun of
Bush. It was a really high Truman. Tracy,
I told you. And then Nixon,
what's, what was Truman's down to?
22 okay.
This is the,
this is what his approval
rate is on foreign policy.
40% wow. Wow. That's really low man.
Uh Huh.
I think Obama,
it's just like every other thing
that happens in this world.
You probably go into it thinking that
you're going to change it and you're going
to fix it. And did you think,
do you have a great president?
You have high hopes for him? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean I think he's a brilliant man.
You know, I don't, I just don't know
how much the president honestly gets to,
I don't want to even speculate on how
much of an effect of president actually
gets to to push how much,
you know,
how much influence does this one human
being actually have? Do you think?
A lot of it behind closed doors, it was
like, so here's what's going to happen.
Much money involved, man. You're
talking about people that run banks.
You're talking about people that demanded
that they get bailed out by the United
States taxpayer after
fucking the United States.
Taxpayers sideways into a point where
the the economy eroded radically in all
businesses. These people cause this
and they still got bonuses. Okay,
this,
these people caused this and Obama went
on TV and said that they're going to get
the, we're going to, we're going to limit
the amount of money that they receive
as a bonus to $500,000 a paltry sum for
such rich folk Q Magine.
Even saying that as a statement,
we're going to limit the bonuses of the
companies where we have to pay millions
of your dollars. We're going to limit
them out. They steal to 500,000 yeah,
we've put a cap on it. No, go to bed.
And then like your whole bomb that there
might be one of the nuttiest things
that a guy has ever said on television.
We're going to limit the thieves who
ruined the economy to a half a million
dollar bonus.
Like oh good people that
we asked to watch over.
Hey you guys are the financial guys,
right?
Please watch over this
fucking thing with numbers.
Cause I have kids and I got a job
but I don't have time to do this.
So do we have, do we have
a guy, we've got a guy,
he went to Harvard and then if you ever
watched that documentary inside job,
you ever watch that? Holy Shit. It's
not about nine 11 folks. It's about,
it's about the economy crash. It's
an unbelievable, it's incredible.
And the guy who is doing it is
brilliant and he catches these dudes,
corners them and ask them questions
and you see them squirm and panic and,
and then you find out like there's a
lot of these guys that were working in
universities that were
responsible for these studies.
They leave the university and
you get these awesome jobs.
The banks whose policies that
they recommended promoted
this sort of like free
range,
wild kamikaze,
swashbuckling capitalism that cause all
these fucking people to lose their homes.
It causes, these guys get jobs working
for those firms after they leave.
So they're like educators and they're
like, this is should be no problem.
I see this should be no
problem. And then they, they,
they pass all this shit and it's the
most obvious shell game of all time.
It's so in your face. Yeah, it
really is. It's really, look,
it's kind of admirable and stuff.
You want to look at it from
a gangster point of view.
I mean it's the most gangster shit ever.
We glorify gangster rap,
gangster rap can't fuck
with gangster banking. No.
Gangster street is the most
gangster shit of all time.
They've done some gangster shit.
Yeah.
And what it means is that worse than
the gangster shit that's been going on
right now and from the beginning of the
Iraq war, that's pretty gangster too.
You know, I mean that's this one one
destroys lives and financial stakes.
The other one kills lives. It kills
people. It destroys everything.
Like how come that is that that ganking
that gangster ganking that we saw.
How come that's like less offensive than
this financial gangster ganking there
pull pretty gangster fucks
people up bad. Look, it's,
it's madness man. It's, we
are mad. We're mad. Mad,
mad race.
Yeah.
And I think we're getting less mad
but we got to figure this out man.
We can't just keep doing this.
We can't just keep going to war.
I've heard a lot of,
uh,
financial people lately say that
like the worst is yet to come in,
in a coming soon kind of way. You know,
as far as like, oh, eight collapse.
But that's just going to
go way further downhill.
What I heard is that the commercial real
estate crash is a really dangerous one.
Really? I've heard that once. A
real dangerous one. That commercial,
like once you have residential
real estate crash, like that one,
there's a commercial one that's
much larger apparently. Allegedly.
I don't understand that though. So even
me saying that, it's just bullshit.
I Dunno what keeps it up.
I don't know how the fuck they rescue
the economy or did they even rescue the
economy? You know, should the bank's
been allowed to fail? Who's right?
Peter Schiff is Peter Schiff. Right. You
know, I don't know. I don't understand it.
I don't understand any of
it. I don't know, man. I,
I'm definitely not the mind to put that
together, but it's, it's pretty bad.
I think. You know what? I know for sure
though, this is not the only way to do it,
right?
This is not the only way to do it.
This whole stocks and bonds and
derivatives and like you guys have created
fucking chaos.
You have a chaotic system and
that system is fucking awful.
It's like windows NT from like 1997 and
you'd go inside of it and start fucking
with the registry and bed yourself and
like you don't know what the fuck is in
this crazy economy. The amount of
influence that affects the politicians,
which affects the laws being passed,
which affects the judges being elected,
which affects the decisions being made
that literally changed the entire scope
of the nation and it's all motivated
by money. Yeah, yeah, it is.
And the other thing that,
the big advantage that those guys have
that work in that field is they have a
specific knowledge that basically the
overwhelming majority of people can't
grasp. Like not because we're not capable,
we're just not well versed in this.
Right. And people start talking about
derivatives and short sales and all this.
Most people are going, I don't know what
the fuck you're talking about. Yeah,
I don't know. So I'm talking about
when I said it that that goes,
but then that makes things
go unregulated unchecked.
It's like when doctors have a conversation
or pilots and they start getting into
the specifics of their
field. At a certain point, if
you're not one of those people,
you're like,
I don't know what you're talking about
and it's not for you. And you're like,
okay,
except this one really affects
most of us a great deal,
but we don't know what the
fuck is happening. Yeah.
To me and might as well be once people
start talking about golf scores. Sure.
He was six under and the five
get to birdies and an eagle man.
What are you saying? Yeah, of course.
And he took a Mulligan. What? Golf Guy?
No, I've never even played Guy Shot
Jim Furich shot a 59 last week.
I have no idea what that means. See, you
just said it right there. Pretty curable.
Yeah. That, that numbers thing
is a scary one to not be,
to not to be math illiterate like I
am. I'm with you. Quite frightening.
I'm with you. What do you think of one 14,
one 14. Is that a good score? For what?
For a boxing. If you watch the
Mayweather. Oh, Jesus Christ.
That woman who also scored,
um,
a Paki out losing to
Bradley's. Yeah. Tim Bradley.
That lady's crazy. She has a different
view of boxing than most people.
I got lucky man. I, uh, I was,
I had a show in Lauderdale and I
was doing it at the, at the Improv,
which is connected to the
hard rock casino. So I knew
the fight and I was like,
I'm gonna miss the fight, whatever. I
had two shows. I mean I take my time,
I finished, should I get paid?
I'm just like hanging out.
I walked back to my room and as I enter
the casino, and this is in Hollywood,
Florida,
there are a fuck an extra 3000
people in the casino. I'm like,
what is going on? Every monitor in the
casino showing the fight. So I was like,
oh great. And it was only
the end of the third round.
So I got to watch from basically round
four on the whole casino showed the
fight. That's incredible.
Everybody stopped.
There were so many people stopped in,
in like in,
in between slot machines,
just like looking up just
to watch this fight. It was,
it was incredible to see that spectacle,
the people watching it and yeah, I mean
we watched, like I said, the rest of the,
after the end of round
three on and you know,
I think even to like novice boxing,
people like Floyd pretty much put on a
clinic, you know? Yeah. It was ridiculous.
I mean this woman squirted even even,
it's crazy.
I think even I think somebody who didn't
know what's going on like we're talking
about. Yeah. Would note
that it wasn't even,
well I think that there's some crazy
people out there and I think there's also
the possibility of corruption and both
of those need to be considered as options
either.
She's crazy and she just likes to judge
Shit professionally that she has no idea
about. I mean, I never talked to,
I haven't talked to a single person that
thought it even made a bit of sense.
It's not like one of those,
well you know what,
she favors defense and the shell
defense is very impressive.
And he did land a couple of heart
counters like, no, no, no, no.
There was no one's saying that like
this is if you thought that he won that
fight or you thought it was a draw,
you're a crazy person.
The fact that your track record
now includes the Pacquiao,
Bradley, this, that's what
those are both on your resume.
That lady does not pay attention
either. She does not pay attention. No,
she's crazy. Or She's getting paid.
Right. I don't want to say that you did.
I'm glad Brian Red Band said that
and not me because I sometimes Brian,
I work in the presence of the Nevada state
athletic commission and I would never
accuse them of such a thing. Right?
However, if I was an investigator,
I would look into it sharply. Yeah,
yeah. There's just something wrong.
There's just something wrong, and if it's
not corruption, which I hope it's not,
it's just incompetence and either way,
it shouldn't be tolerated. You didn't,
you know something. No one
deserves their job. Right.
Especially when it's that kind of a job.
You don't deserve that job.
You have that job because you're
supposed to be a professional at it.
You're supposed to be really good at it.
And when you're unbelievably,
embarrassingly, Baz and him were
in bearably unbearably unbearably,
but I went in Blair ugly. It's not a
word, but she so bad. It's criminal.
It's criminal.
It's like me teaching Spanish lessons,
but I don't know how to speak Spanish.
Right. So if I tell you to speak Spanish,
that she would be criminal. Criminal.
It's not. It's not. Okay. Snoop Lion,
we jackpot wins. Pound of weed off
the Mayweather fight. Oh, he bet.
A pound of weed.
All that's hilarious.
Looking at him with a pound of weed
and a captain America shirt on.
He's a bad ass. Look at this guy who
did the bed it with Scott to say,
you know how much is a
pound of weed these days?
I don't know.
A Mexican guy named Lou Lou.
That's hilarious. I've never had
a pound of weed in my life. No.
It's about $40,000. That's insane. I've
never even had more than an ounce. Like,
I don't want to carry a lot
of weed around. No, no, no,
no. I understand. I've seen,
uh, a quarter a quarter pound
QP. If I saw a bag that big,
I would assume the next thing I want to
hear his boots kicking the door and get
all your fucking, and I'm going to
like, okay, I'm a comedian, drug dealer.
What's scary in Ohio?
Allegedly my dealer growing up in college,
that's how much he would
have. Oh Hi. Oh that's scary.
Cause like he would have three pit bulls,
two chows and just like,
like you'd come in this house and
then like all these crazy dogs,
you just pull up the humongous
bag and put it right there.
And he like trusted me.
So he like showed me all the shit
he had and like all the secrets,
like pounds of weed that he has
hidden everywhere. Hod is crazy.
I grew up around that.
A guy here who did, who
deal that here had um,
like a big SUV,
like an Escalade and he had
compartments built in there.
Um, where the way it was rigged was that
the radio station had to be tuned to a
certain channel and that would unlock,
then he would be able to
unlock the compartments.
So it had to be like a 91.7 and
then he would go click, click.
That's so crazy as to transport.
Like you know that a guy went to
jail for a long time because he was
constructing those. Oh really? Yeah.
He went to jail for like a real stretch
and they accused him of aiding and
abetting.
Somehow or another they set this guy up.
Okay me build like hidden compartments,
hidden compartments,
jail. Did you ever, oh here we go.
Guys
gets one of my mods.
This has to do with a CD drive
and a secret compartment.
One of many of my inventions.
And I know they've used CD drives before
but not in vehicles and as far as to my
knowledge and not like this. And
what I've done is uh, this is a key
and it's a battery stick.
Your tongue ship, it would
zap you don't do that stupid.
Anyways.
And these are two taps.
It is really a nine volt battery and
the power supply goes through this.
Open up my event,
which reveals my secret compartment,
and I'm basically took the CD drive apart,
use the the bare basics.
No,
this is total extra cash in your change
to it and whatnot.
So he pushes his result.
It's just a regular nine volt batteries
holding out. He puts it right there. Oh,
come on now guys.
James Bond,
you know your wallet,
Your Keys, little extra.
He said, oh, you know your wallet.
I thought he said, Pino Pinot noir
glasses, chilled bitches.
Stepping on my 79 impala
glass of wine can make it a game
for this around, and then it closes.
That's still flip it to go in and
flip it to go out. That's insane.
You change the battery.
That is insane. That
[inaudible]
super boy. I was thinking, Damn. That
was awesome, man. That was awesome.
Do you ever see the French connection?
You've seen it, right? Yes ma'am. Oh,
so long ago. Those Gene Hackman, right?
Yeah. It's fucking awesome movie, man.
I don't know. I don't know. I
don't remember a thing about it.
I remember it was awesome, but I watch
it to watch it again. Smuggling. Yes.
And it's so good. It's like
a classic, um, you know,
cop fucking carbon bad
guy movie from that era.
So I think it's a late seventies movie.
It's so good. You've seen it, Brian.
You got to see it. Okay. Is it about like
something like that? It's like trucks.
Yeah, absolutely. It's a heroin. Yeah.
This was the guy I was talking about.
His name is Alfred and Naya and it says
he was a genius at installing secret
compartments in cars and uh,
and so they were used to smuggle drugs
without his knowledge and now he's in
trouble if they were used to
smuggle drugs without his knowledge,
he figured it wasn't a problem, he
was wrong and it said, uh, he, they,
they locked him up, man. Wow.
He lived in the valley and um,
he would set up these compartments
like in the trucks back seat,
the trucks back seat where he would,
he rigged up a set of hydraulic cylinders
that link to the vehicle's electrical
system. The only way to make the seats
slide forward and reveal its secret was by
pressing and holding four
switches simultaneously to, uh,
for the power door locks
and two for the windows.
So who press all four of those the same
time and it would open up the back seat.
So awesome.
Yeah.
He said the seal was no longer responsible
to the switch combination that no
amount of jiggling could make it budge.
Pleaded with the guy to take a look.
Okay.
You know, this is how Bieber
roles, he's got like the high tech,
the most high tech whenever
probably if Bieber. Yeah, yeah.
If they pull that motherfucker over all
the time and there's never has anything
in his car,
but yet,
like TMZ always has pictures of him like
holding bongs out window. Oh, brilliant.
Water into the,
so they set this guy up, listen to this.
The guy's name was a a [inaudible]. Right.
And so, um, there was this,
a dude named Esteban and he was saying
that the switch to the combination
doesn't work anymore and no amount of
jiggling could get it to work again.
And so this guy shows up to fix it and
he's a little suspicious because there's
nothing elite. There's nothing
illegal about building traps,
which are commonly used to hide
everything from pricey jewelry to illegal
handguns. But the activity runs
afoul of carrier California law.
If an installer knows for certain that
his compartment will be used to transport
drugs. So if the guy told him that
it's going to transport drugs,
then he has a responsibility to either
call the police or not building or what
have you. The maximum penalty is three
years in prison. And so this guy,
the guy who got arrested, he thought
it was wise to deviate from a standard,
no questions asked policy before green.
So he suspected this guy and he said,
there's nothing in there I
should know about is there.
Esteban assured him that he needn't
worry, I'll say, this is fucked up man.
So he's saying don't worry
about it. Like, yeah.
So the guy didn't give in to saying,
Hey,
I'm going to use it for this,
and the guy goes, all right,
I'll build it for you anyway.
Yeah. Well this is weird, man.
This is the lock that guy up. They, they,
they fucking set this guy up because this
guy was making compartments for people
but not asking any questions.
That's what it was.
But I don't think that's illegal.
I think you're allowed to hide shit cause
you're going to let you know what if
you have money, do you
want to leave? You know,
something expensive or you own a
jewelry store. Yeah, no. Well yeah,
if you have expensive stuff
on you all the time, yeah,
you should be able to hide that you
own a business. It's a cash business.
You want to transplant.
You can assume that if someone can
hide something in their home that they
shouldn't be able to hide
something in their car.
That's your property to this is that
weirdness of like searching people's cars,
man. You know, because you don't come to
a person's house and search their house.
Like why are you searching their
car? Yeah. Like you, you're, you.
Cause you know that people transport
drugs, things with their car.
But at the end of the day,
it's fucking private property and whether
there is $1,000 in cash in the back
seat,
you're gonna steal from us because you
think there were were buying drugs with
it.
That's happened before where people,
like there was a stripper who
had like $1 million in her trunk.
This crazy bitch like made $1 million
and was going to buy a business and she
had this money,
he's got arrested and the cops had to
give the money back to her because they
suspected her of being a drug dealer.
And then she had to document all of
her pay or hone and show all dogs.
Do you have any? Oh my God. Like
they say dat ass, but the, the,
you know the cops took that money as
if like you can't have money if you had
money. It has to come from drugs. A
lot of money. Yeah, but why can't you?
Don't worry, I'm don't people have
houses? How did they buy a house? Yeah.
Who's to say you can't just go to a guy
with a fucking trunk full of cash and
buy a house. You can, you know,
just because everybody else
uses a fucking credit card.
If you decide you hate credit cards,
you want to store it all
in a safe in your house,
and I only know the combination does it?
The cop have to look in there and
see if there's anything wrong.
If he sees that there's money in there,
hey,
what are you doing with
all this good stuff?
What do you do with all this
stuff that everybody earns?
Why do you have to declare? I was
thinking about the border thing. I mean,
I assume that you have to declare
money big so that they can investigate.
Yes. Whether what's the source of that
money? What do you have that money for?
But there's this whole
thing you have to declare.
If you have over 10,000 let's say going
into Ken or coming back in the United
States, right? Right. What if you have
a lot of money and, right. Why do you,
why do I have to explain to you
that I don't have this problem?
But I've thought about it before. Like
we're like, you know, obviously they're,
they're asking so it'd be so
that if somebody does like
they don't say they have
it, then they do with it. Then they
find that they have 15,000 in cash.
They're going to be like,
why do you have this much cash was I do,
I wonder if you have to like when
you report it, how's that work?
If you have to report the Alex,
let's say you're some crazy ball or type
character. Yeah. And you know, he'll like,
who would you be like if you were
going to be a mall or type character,
we have to be a black guy.
Right? Who would you be? What?
Which rapper would you be?
The walks around with a suitcase of cash.
Let's say you're Floyd Mayweather cause
he would walk around with suitcases full
of cats. Absolutely. Why can't
Floyd Mayweather? He probably,
they probably wouldn't let them in
Canada because he's got some domestic
violence charges. That's what
he did his 30 days or whatever.
They might not even let you know because
Canada is pretty strict about letting
you know shit like that. They don't
fuck around. But if he did get through,
he probably would get through
like a hundred grand and
a backpack and some Gucci
sack or something like that.
Did you see the all access for him and
Canelo? No, I didn't. I didn't. Dude.
I've watched them before,
but like I didn't see it this time.
He sends one of his girls to go pick up
some of his gambling debt is gambling
money hoodie one.
She goes in this like ostrich skin.
I don't know who the fuck my ex at some
super expensive bag and the guy puts
$480,000 in the bag and then
she walks it out of there.
It gets in her car and drives it to
money. Mayweather. Hey Floyd. Yeah, he's,
he was headed to his house. But you want
on Duke? Do you know how crazy that is?
Duke, Maryland. She's saying he's, he's
gambling that kind of money. Oh, I mean,
he always taught,
he takes the photos of his betting slips.
I know he's crazy.
It's $480,000 he won.
And they're not even like,
it's sometimes his bets are like these
like kind of side bet like prop bets.
They're like,
where it's like,
uh, I'm betting on who's the first
to 12 points in his basketball game.
You know what I mean?
Not even like the outcome of the game.
Like he's bitten this shit like that
where it's a total just gambling rush kind
of battery life.
I'll put 25 grand that it's the 70 sixers.
Well, you want to know what's
interesting? They have, uh,
found a direct correlation
between head trauma and, uh,
addiction to gambling. Really? Yeah.
I brought it up to Dana white because
Dana White was in here and Danny,
Danny used to be a boxer and Dana was
talking about his gambling like Dana
gambles, like insanity. He
wants 7,000,001 night. What?
He lost a million.
That's the most he's ever
lost is 1 million the most
he's ever won a 7 million.
And it's gambling always
on like on sporting events.
That's where he likes to gamble on it.
I don't know what the,
I think he's playing cards.
He's won $7 million. Yes, yes.
Yeah.
I can't even remember. I mean he, he
goes off because it poker, I don't know.
I think he plays blackjack. I don't
know what the fuck you play. Blackjack.
I went into that a high stakes room.
Uh,
once I saw a guy and people stopped
or to watch him to do blackjack,
he was doing 10,000 a hand and we were
all like to see and Grantland and they
were like, no, like bust, take 10,000.
He would put 10,000 in chips back there.
And it was, I mean it was super
entertaining to watch, but I was like, oh,
I can't imagine doing that man.
I can't get out just talking about
10,000 and it goes like that.
I mean it has gone in seconds
and so Dana must do it.
That style where it's like 25
grand a hand, that kind of,
Oh yeah, that's a, that's
really unique with gambling.
You know the gambling for like money like
in Vegas type gambling is that you can
the the, it can shift within
seconds, seconds easy. If
you're gambling on a game,
it's a whole game. You have one
hour for this game to take place.
I kind of like gambling on games cause
I don't even like sports but if I had
some money invested, yeah, like it would
make it more exciting. It absolutely does.
It has that effect to the umpteenth
degree. It's like if I go to Vegas,
I'm like say say if you and I went and
there was some kickbox and going on
because they're doing this new thing
for a spike TV. Yeah. Glory. Glory.
Is this a super high
level kickboxing league?
It's like the best kick boxers on the
planet earth and the fucking, the,
the fights are incredible.
Like go con Saki and Daniel,
Geeta and Tyro and Splunk's guys
are fucking assassins. Right.
I would like to go see that Shit live and
if we went to see that shit live, yeah,
and we were ringside,
you know,
we're going to bet some
money Tommy buttons now would
you bet based not knowing
anything about the guys, how, you know,
I would never do that. He would pay.
What if I wanted it for a goof? Yeah.
No, but let's say not for like if you,
if we're talking about this particular,
would you know about the guy?
Like do you know those guys who they are?
Yeah, the high, the highest level guys.
I know, but there's so many more
kickboxers than there are MMA guys.
There's a lot of MMA guys that,
I don't know really. There's,
there's a certain number where you can
only keep so many in your brain. Yeah.
You know that there's,
like they say like close friends or
people that you're in contact with on a
regular basis. You have 150 names that
you can kind of keep going. Yeah. Yeah.
The 150 people that you have
relations with, everything after that,
it's just like, yeah. You know,
I don't know, have a lot of,
I mean like you in particular store
a lot of data about guys fighting who
they've fought and you remember the
fight where they fought, how the,
how he won that particular fight.
That's a lot of extra knowledge. Yeah.
There. But that's because there's
nothing else in there. Right.
There's no other sports in there. Oh I
see what you mean. Yeah. You know. Yeah.
There's no room, there's no
room for hockey. There's no
room for basketball. Yeah.
So all like when I start talking
about like fights, like Oh, you know,
he lost Igov Chan Chan and he got
killed in the first round, came back,
fought a few times, but we never really
saw him again. I, you know, there's no,
there's no basketball in their confusing.
I see what you mean.
Cause I'm kind of that to a degree
that way with college football. Like,
I have a lot of data in there and I
remember names and I remember games and I
remember the year. But that's way more
numbers in the crazy thing is like,
well sometimes I'm amazed that I
remember who recruited the guy. Whoa.
And what high school he
went to the whole migration.
That's a hunter s Thompson's famous
story about, uh, talking to Nixon.
Have you ever heard that? No, I don't
think so. I don't think so. Oh Dude. Um,
he spent time in a car with Nixon.
Really?
Hunter s Thompson did before
he was president? No, Nixon
was president. Oh Wow.
Okay. And he, uh,
he rode with him in a car and a Nixon
and him just talked football. He,
he knew that hunter was a football
fan. Right. Your ride with me.
If we only talk football because football
fans love to talk football with other
football fans. And the runner
was a huge football plant fan.
So he got in the backseat with Nixon
and they talked about football.
He said he was amazed that like he knew
about one guy who played one year with
one team and he knew where he went to
college and he let us, he was like,
I was blown away. It's like
he's a real legit, he goes,
it might be the only thing that he
didn't lie about it didn't hunter killed
himself after football season.
It was right. He was like,
he waited for like Superbowl and all
that and kills like in February or
something. He had been apparently talking
about killing himself for a long time.
He was in some pretty serious pain. He
had hip replacements and a on top of it,
the boozing and the coke.
He had just red lined his brain.
If you ever listen to a
hunter like later in life,
pull up a hunter s Thompson
on Conan O'brien show.
It's really sad.
And this is coming from someone
who's a huge hunter s Thompson Fan.
And so in fact, my favorite all
time documentary if I have to do it,
if I have to tell people one is a goof,
I always go with grizzly man.
Cause Christina was hilarious to me.
Do you mean could it,
do you mean a Letterman would I
sent Conan? Yeah. No, Conan. Conan.
If there's one, trust me, cause
he's, it's much, he's much older.
When he's doing the one on Conan
grizzly man, you'd find hysterical.
It's hilarious. I love it. I watched it
again last week, once it a hundred times.
But Gonzo, the life and work of Dr.
Hunter s Thompson is fucking brilliant.
Really. It's an amazing, amazing,
I miss your watch documentary.
I should watch that. They, that
you can't find a dude. There we go.
Hunter s Thompson. Is
this a bad copy? We're,
can we give you better
listen to him talk and talk.
You barely understand them.
Good.
You can't even hear that. Go. Go to
the one where they're at the desk.
If you go further, further
back, he's sitting at the
desk with Conan and he's, uh,
they're talking and it's like Jesus
Christ. You can't put together the saying,
you don't understand a word he's
saying, mumble slur, mumble, mumble,
mumble. But then if you go back to his
early stuff, you go back to, uh, the, the,
the documentary. It's absolutely
brilliant. It's when he's
running for sheriff, uh,
Avastin and, um, they start, you know,
he starts talking about the laws that are
in place today and why it's a gendered,
this disrespect for law enforcement
operators, uh, law enforcement officers,
because they know that these laws,
especially marijuana laws are bullshit.
Cops know they're bullshit. The kids are
on their bullshit. Yeah. And he was like,
you know,
we got to put a stop to this or there's
going to be a revolution in this country
and you know, and they're like,
it's pretty fucking intense, man.
Yeah. He does a shot. Throw up.
Hello. It's like, that was
pretty good. That's beautiful.
Horrible trick.
That was good. Very good. I to
come live with you for a month,
maybe umbrella some whiskey
and we need a machine gun.
Did you remembering we fired
this? Yeah. In Arizona.
That was awesome.
I went to the Arizona gun club is called
Phoenix gun club. Something like that.
Yeah.
It's amazing. Those
things aren't sane. Yeah.
We fired some crazy ass machine
guns. They're fun, man. Yeah,
we're shooting it. Some I need to
get a place where I can shoot guns.
That's what I need next.
It's so much fun to shoot a high power.
But the problem is whenever you get a
big piece of land that you could shoot
guns on the assume you're starting to call
it. Yeah. You know, what are they doing?
Well they go up there and they just shoot
guns. Yeah, but in California they do.
And then sometimes there's stuff
that you need to shoot with a gun,
which is another problem.
You know,
I don't want to go to Ohio and they
think I'm gay. Why? Cause the number one,
look what if number one now if all of a
sudden I start moving there, you know,
it's Kinda weird that you
guys are both Columbus.
Well there's more in basements to
fucking in Ohio. Easy too sweet.
Is it a,
is it a prison type thing where there's
just not as many girls and I don't know.
Is that what goes down now? It's
go creepy. I think those guys,
they would find you guys irresistible.
Smart.
They figured how to start their
own community in West Hollywood.
They figured out how to start
their own community in Columbus.
You know what doesn't happen
like that though? Lesbians.
Lesbians don't really form me very many
lesbian neighborhoods. I guess not.
I don't really think of, I
don't know. Right. I don't
even know if one, not really.
I can't think of one word. I'm sure
they exist. Yeah. I can't think of one.
Gay people have a whole
islands. Fire Island. Yeah.
Take over New York. It's almost all gay
fire Ireland is, yeah, it's gay. It's all,
it's like 98% gay.
Yeah,
and then there's a few hangers on some
old people that don't know what's up. Oh,
the strange.
They Russell Lesbians have the
dinosaur get together, right? Oh, well,
there's a lot of lesbian golf club pros
for sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What else?
Pool. Really? Yes. High level
women, professional pool players.
A lot of gay softball, softball, but
a few really softball. Oh yeah. Yeah.
What is it about girls and
sports doesn't make them gay?
I guess there's the natural association,
right.
I know those girls all over the
country to think we're serious. I know.
I mean, you look like a guy
and you play like a guy.
That's not what we're saying first.
You can without a doubt, absolutely.
Be a beautiful woman and be in a sports.
Sure.
And doing sports and competing in sports.
Don't get me wrong,
I saw Gabby Reese at the airport. Whoa.
That's a lot of woman. Whoa. I did a, um,
a celebrity volleyball game with
her and Jonathan Taylor Thomas,
that's his favorite way back in
the, does a, yeah, it was many,
many, many moons ago. And uh,
she's big beautiful woman. Yeah.
Making fucking warrior
babies with that absolute,
her husband's a big beautiful
man layer. Additional surfer. Oh,
he looks like rock right out of a
fucking 1950s movie above the beach of
California hairs. Like amazing. Yep.
Down and you people are fucking yoked.
Big yoked. Beautiful Man. Yeah. The
two of them have pretty sex. Oh,
I'm sure it's, they should study it.
Yeah. They should study it. And like,
you know one day when they invent
artificial people, what do you want to be?
You want to be some artificial frail
little fucking insect like person.
I want to be layered,
layered and Gabriela.
She gives birth.
She probably just reaches in and
grabs the kid strongly. Fh Is,
oh my God, she doesn't have
to screen and they're both,
they're both loves it in their and
in their forties and they look,
they were together. They had
the whole family together
so I was like, he's fairly,
it looks amazing.
It was straight out of a magazine.
Did you hear that? You got herpes
infected monkeys in Florida. I believe it.
I was there this weekend. Yo,
Dude, Florida does not play games.
Tommy bonds by the way,
developed in Florida. It's true.
It's one of the few things besides
herpes infected monkeys that have come
straight from Florida. Tommy Vaughn says,
right high school, Vero Beach, Florida.
I don't know.
They said that there's a fucking
slew of herpes infected wild monkeys.
There's as many as a third
of a thousand of them.
Then he adds a thousand of them.
There's going to be spreading a lot.
There's a lot of fucking going
on in the monkey world. Yeah.
Monkeys don't stop
monkeys on ask each other.
Do you have anything I should
know about before they, fuck they,
that's 100% of herpes. They
fuck everybody. Yeah, of course.
Every monkey fucks every monkey.
The only thing that they don't do is
we'll chimps at least as mother and son
don't have sex.
That's common primate restriction though.
The mother won't have sex with the
son, but the dad, everybody else,
the dad fucks the sun. Really?
Everybody fucks everybody.
They fucked the dad fucks the
daughters that they fucked cousins.
If fuck sisters, everybody fucks
everybody except the mom won't fuck this.
Very interesting. Thanks
mom. Yeah, this is,
uh, well, I mean it's just really
funny. How many endangered,
how many dangerous invasive
species there are in Florida?
When you stopped to think about it,
they started to find Nile crocodiles.
They found pythons that are so big.
They eat alligators. Jesus. Yeah.
And now they're finding these fucking
crazy herpes. He infected monkeys.
There's a thousand feral rhesus
monkeys living in Florida right now.
And among those scooped up by
wildlife officials over the years,
most were found to be carriers of herpes
B and this week the colony was declared
a public health hazard.
It's believed that a small handful of
the wild animals originally landed in the
state and the 1930s
courtesy of colonel toony,
a tour operator who wanted to give the
visitors a Tarzan inspired experience of
Florida's Silver River State Park too.
We reportedly kept the monkey
sequestered on an island,
but they learned to swim to shore.
Wow.
Easily reaching the
mainland and moving out,
putting down roots as far as Jackson
Ville over a hundred miles away.
This is amazing. And these are, these
are they,
they're not even contained,
like they're just out roaming
around or they're contained.
They're roaming.
There's a thousand of them roaming Jesus.
It says herpes doesn't cause serious
symptoms in these particular animals.
In fact,
it's fairly common amongst them,
but in humans it can lead to neurological
impairment or fatal in Cephalonia
Mope, Sef, flow, my late, my likeness,
and Cephalon my Linus.
Why do they do that?
Why did they insist on making
it work so fucking difficult?
That shit's ridiculous. These
moments in sef a low, definitely.
I Litas lettuce,
my lightest.
I guess it's lettuce. No, it would be I,
because there's no e
after tea before and I,
or is there an inflammation of the
brain and spinal cord leading to death?
Florida's rhesus monkeys are known
to act aggressively towards people.
They're racist. They're biting
people. Yeah, they're probably racist.
They probably hate white people.
So they bite people and then you get,
you get a murderous form of
herpes that barely affects them,
barely affects them, but will kill you.
This is so, they are essentially toxic.
It's mean, it's very little difference
between that, having that and being toxic.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're talking about something that you
can give a person that will fuck them up.
It's me. Well, how's that
different than a poison? Hey Miss,
because it's a bacteria. Great winters
in Florida. Just all I got to say. Yeah.
There's a Cuban treefrog
problem in, uh, in Florida too.
They're, uh, they're really
noisy. So these animals,
they move into these areas and the people
like have a real hard time sleeping.
Oh, she's, because they're really,
really fucking loud and they're,
they're trying to find out
like one of the research,
some of the research that we're doing
recently in human beings and happiness and
harmony and peace. One of the things
they're showing is that we need quiet.
Like people need quiet. It's not
just, I would like to get some quiet.
Now you actually do need certain amounts
of quiet. You can't, you, you need sleep.
And during that sleep you
need to be able to rest.
And if you're fucking constantly
inundated with sounds,
you might not ever totally rest.
You might drift in and out or [inaudible]
they could fucking red line your mind.
It can really fuck you up. So these
frogs, they move in their, their culture.
Cuban tree flogs there in tree frogs
there in central and south Florida.
And they're there.
They double the rate of their calls.
Native Green Tree frogs. Dot. Hmm. Oh,
in the presence of this is so crazy.
They're so loud that in
the presence of them,
the native frogs have doubled
their rate of calls as well.
So it's just insanity.
They're super loud and crazy.
And then the other frogs have doubled
their rate of calls because they have to
try to keep up with these crazy new,
they're basically Joey Diaz as a frog.
It's a big, loud, crazy Cuban
frog. That's insane. Yeah.
That's nuts.
They have unforeseen ecological effects,
Tennessee and says that by doubling it's
called rate the green frog makes its
presence more obvious, which is likely
to make it more vulnerable to predation.
Wow. So they're going to kill off the
other frogs, but making them stupid
till they actually get, they got
competitive about, Yup. The frog calls,
they were like, yeah, well it makes
sense. Yeah, of course. It must be sexual.
Right when they, when they make
calls. What else are you doing?
Sexual or it's like territorial, you
know, about like threatening my territory.
Right. And what's the territory
about sex? I guess so, yeah.
They're just trying to get their frog
freak on fraud freaks. They found, uh,
the largest wild Burmese python in
Florida recently captured in euthanize the
for, this is the largest one they've
ever caught Florida 17 feet long.
Do you think a lot of this
stuff going there? I mean,
part of it is like that it's made up.
The place is a swamp like states a swamp,
but then it's also proximity to like
wear a lot of people end up going like
people from the islands, right. Coming up
with shit. It's the perfect storm. Yeah.
Florida is the perfect
storm. Yeah. First of all,
you've got the highest level of Oxycontin
addiction in prescription on the
planet earth. That's Florida. Florida has
10 times more oxycontin prescriptions.
Then the rest of the country
combined. Really? Yes.
That's a lot. So then,
okay, so you got that right.
You've got this crazy number of
people who are on Oxycontin's.
Then you've got Cuban immigrants,
including a slew that Castro released,
the Castro sent out because
they were prisoners.
That's what Scarface is based on.
Yeah.
Then you've got the cocaine industry
in my and mental patients too. Oh yeah.
Dan Marino, Dan Marines from Florida. Now
he's from, he's from, he was just, yeah,
he played for the Miami Dolphins.
Yeah. So you've got that. Okay.
Then you've got the amount of banks that
were set up with cocaine money. Whoa.
Jesus. That's, that's when you
start getting really crazy. Yes.
Because you find the numbers and
you go, oh my God, this is insane.
Why there's so many banks.
There's more banks per capita in Miami
than anywhere else in the country.
Then you got no state income tax. What
type does that attract? And no income tax.
And it's like this reputation
of being a place where he,
eastern gangsters went south.
I mean it's always been there.
Like they go south and dumped bodies.
They go south and hide out. That goes,
I mean they would get in a Cadillac
and they would drive from New York to
Florida. I'm going to give my mother
a nice house in Florida. Yeah.
And then they would also,
the big thing before Florida was they
would take boats or jets or whatever to
Cuba.
Before Cuba fell like in the 1950s.
Like Kennedy would go to Cuba and that
was the spot. They would go to Cuba,
but people go to Cuba.
Cuba was the shit they would
go and dance and drink and,
and it was supposed to
be fucking incredible.
And then when the shit hit the
fan and everybody had a flea,
let's just stay around Miami.
Fuck it. Going to need to go here.
And Miami's basically is nothing about
it looks like any American city at all.
It's totally, I mean it's great
time. He's a great city. It's a fun,
fun city. But it's very international.
Oh yeah. It's very international.
You are an asshole sometimes when you
walk into a store there and speak English,
just like they literally are like,
who the fuck are you doing?
So there's that, you
know, and then there's,
it's attached to the southerly
parts of what Georgia and what else,
what else is it attached to drive to
South Carolina? No, Alabama. Yeah,
there you go.
You Go Bama,
Mississippi. And it's
interesting because the, uh,
the other thing that's interesting
is that the further south you go,
the more international cosmopolitan
when you're in like northern Florida,
northern Florida, you might as well be
an Alabama. Oh, definitely. You really,
you don't have to go that far
north. No, no. You're that
far central. No, you do not.
Yeah. Northern forest tree yet
it's a different out Tallahassee,
that shit's country.
I remember when when I was in high school.
Cool. And we would go to this
place called Belle glade.
Belle glade is basically
inland from Palm Beach. I,
so palm beach is billionaire's row,
right?
West Palm Beach has nothing to do
with that. It's just, you know,
like poor and uh, you know, it has, I
mean obviously it has some nice areas,
but then you have like rednecks and then
you go further in that Lake Okeechobee.
Belle glade is sugarcane.
And you could smell yourself,
you could smell Belle glade way
before you get there. Like the draft,
like burning sugar cane and it
doesn't smell sweet, you know,
it doesn't smell good.
And you get out there and you're like,
this is like an entirely different world.
Like it had nothing to do with anything.
It was so rural and you know,
it was all about the soil there.
Mk City and, and the, uh, the,
the place had you would think you
were in Alabama or in Georgia,
you know, some rural part of Georgia.
And that was just like I said,
a couple of hours in from West Palm Beach
that, that cartoon of Bugs Bunny Song
off Florida. What year was that from?
Uh,
it looks like about six days.
Do you think that that was really what
he did or did someone create that to for
a joke and the new day and age? Oh
No, no, no. That's from a cartoon.
So he really did saw away
Florida. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So was Florida where Elmer Fudd lived
and I can't remember that episode.
Hating on flow. Was Florida
shitty back then to where,
where did Lucy and Ricky live?
They live in Florida
cause he was Cuban, right? He was Cuban.
Was that Miami to question? I don't know.
I Love Lucy.
Here we go.
Isn't it funny that they're like no one
had any problem with that as like an
interracial relationship or, uh, you know,
inter cultural relationship.
Like back then,
like being a Cuban man was
like very sophisticated.
It wasn't like if you tried
to do a Mexican and her, like,
people would have a problem with
that. Yeah, it was, you know,
it was okay to have it that way.
It wasn't even considered. I mean,
not that they're different races,
but Hispanic,
a lot of people will actually all racist.
Do Look at Hispanic and Hispanic people.
It's being different than Hawaii
course of course. But that back then,
did you know that
big bunny bugs bunny?
Why did they do that?
Why is bugs metaphor and that's what I
need to know now. Do you know that a desi,
he had such a massive ego
that does Ernesto. Yeah.
He had a real problem with the name
of the show being an I love Lucy.
So they, he was like, the
show should be like, you know,
I love Desi. Right. But they told
him, yeah, but who sang? I Love Lucy.
I was saying he's an idiot. Yeah. And
they were like, and he was like, oh yeah.
And they convinced him. Oh my God. They're
showed, basically it's, it's, you sang it.
So the show's really about, you know,
how do we know that that's true though?
That's it. It's a, all these
stories of her duce or it could be,
it could be saying wad.
They'll tell us,
they'll tell stories about you
some day Tommy buttons and be like,
the fuck I said that.
I didn't fucking say that shit out.
Fuck I said that meanwhile.
Okay.
That was a big fucking popular show
him. Oh yeah. I think the most,
I think the most watched
episode of television ever is,
I love Lucy when she gave birth,
everybody tuned in to see if it was a
boy or a girl. Like it's crazy numbers,
insanity. Like basically most of our
country watch that. When that aired,
it was from six years from 1951 to
1957 and then after the series ended,
a modified version continued for three
more seasons with 13 one hour specials
running from 1957 in 1960. No, Nas,
the Lucille Ball,
Desi Arnaz show and then reruns
as the Lucy Dezi comedy hour.
My name is on that show. Loves that.
This is bullshit. I'm not coming back.
Yeah, I guess I was actually in
1949 that bugs bunny cartoon,
but I think he just, I dunno, he, um,
he's given credit basically
for syndication. Really?
Desi Arnaz he figured it out while he's
the one television used to just air
live. Like you just wow. And
they would just shoot it.
And then he asked for like the prince
one time and they were like, yeah,
you can have the fucking prince.
What are we going to do with that shit?
You fucking idiot. You dumb
Cuban piece of shit. And then,
and then woopsie little while
later he was like, well, you know,
we can repair this. And they were
like, Oh yeah, we could rear that.
That's actually quite funny.
Yeah.
Originally sat in an apartment
building in New York City.
I love Lucy centers on Lucy Ricardo,
Lucille ball, and her singer,
bandleader husband,
Ricky Ricardo
along with their best friends
and landlords. Fred Mertz,
the landlord and Ethel Mertz. Wow. Yeah.
That's shows those shows man,
like the honeymooners.
That's a window into
another time. Yeah, sure.
They watched and Lucille ball
watching the honeymooners,
the honeymooners every week.
Ralph Pram did with threatened
to beat the fuck out of his,
not just occasional. Yeah. Every
fucking week he would like.
He would talk about punching her in
the face and knocking her to the moon.
He deserved it but stopped.
Stop.
Just stop and think about like culturally
how crazy people were not that long
ago.
We need to understand what a giant
change has happened in our culture.
I think one of the best ways to really
document it is to watch old shows.
Watch what they, what they excepted back
then and watch it. They accept today.
There's a newspaper article I just
saw from somebody posted it I think on
Twitter and it was,
it was the ass they pulled guy. It was an
old newspaper article they pulled guys,
whether it's okay to spank
a woman and the answers,
they pulled like five or six guys. There's
an old article and they were all like,
absolutely like she
needs it and if she did,
if she's out of line and she
doesn't know she's doing,
you're just trying to help her.
And this was a newspaper thing where
they were like, see guys? Yeah.
It was to make you feel okay about
spanking yearly. I tweeted that. Oh,
you tweeted that? Yeah. Okay. I don't
know. I just saw an article. Well,
I might've retweeted it, but either
way I can definitely tweeted it.
I thought that was hilarious.
Hysterical. Yeah. If a woman needs it,
should she be spanked? The best part about
it was rich read it. Let's read. Yeah,
it's so fucking funny.
Why not? Jesus Christ.
If they don't know how to behave
by the time they're adults,
they should be treated like
children and spanked that automate,
make them grow up in a hurry.
If it doesn't at first,
they'll soon get the idea. This
is incredible. I get the idea.
I yes, when they deserve it. As a barber,
I've got a lot of faith in the hairbrush.
Oh my God.
I think there are certain cases
when it is advisable, when it is.
There's no reason why you
shouldn't go right ahead and do it.
I can't knock the idea and my business,
a man sets a lot of the of store sets a
lot of store by the results he can get
with a hairbrush, properly
applied. Nice little smack.
Now here's the counterpoint though.
Sets a lot of store.
Maybe that's a business term back then,
man sets a lot of store.
Are you ready for the
counterpoint? Yes, there is none.
Everybody agrees that that's the best
part is everybody takes the point of view
because this guy parking lot attendant
from Brooklyn, you, Teddy Hillel, you bet.
You Bet.
It teaches them who's boss.
A lot of women tend to
forget this is a man's world.
And a lot of men who stepped down as
boss of a family wished they hadn't
spanking might help get back some of
the respect they lost. Look at Teddy.
Look at that as Joey
Diaz, his cousin. Listen,
cock sock that spank them if they want it.
William Davis,
what does Williamson as a
toy factory owner? Yes. Most
of them have it coming to them anyway.
If they don't,
it will remind them of
how well off they are.
I subscribe to the theory that an ounce
of prevention is worth a pound of cure.
Holy Shit. Look at him. Look
at that evil looking. Fuck.
It looks like Rutger house brother.
Wow.
Does he look like Rutger Hauer and
Robert Dinero? Fuck it looks evil.
That one. A Holtzman. Oh yeah,
he does a little like Holsman
imagine that guy spanking your wife.
Let's see what the other people. That
was the last one. Yep. That's awful.
Oh well that's sort of like what you know,
um,
Dawkins is kind of alluding to totally
that you're dealing with a totally
different time. Absolutely. And he
probably didn't really get over it. Yeah.
He's probably saying that to appear.
Look, it's no big deal. I got over it,
but the reality is, is that guy
probably needs mushrooms in a hug. Yeah.
That guy's still,
he's like avoided psychedelics.
You know where that came
into play big time with,
with that k like that specific world at,
um,
was an issue was the Joe Paterno
thing. Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sandusky. Nobody's arguing that
it was a different era. He was,
he's a rapist and a pedophile.
But people were saying that the way
that paternal handled it was just an old
school guy way of doing it because
he was 80 something years old.
His whole thing was like, you know,
I didn't, I didn't know. And My,
uh,
my way of the way of doing things when
for a guy from his era was like, well,
just, you don't come around here anymore.
Yeah. You know what I mean? Yeah.
It was his way of his way of
policing that type of behavior was,
and that probably was what people would
do to somebody. Like, you hear what,
what Jerry did. Yeah. Jerry's not
welcome here anymore. You know,
that kind of thing. Yeah.
That's considered the
discipline for that guy. Right.
Not let's call authorities and,
and it was like [inaudible] you
know he's out of here. Yeah. Jerry,
you can't fuck my kids. Yeah. You gotta
go away. Stop. That's wrong. Yeah.
You can't come to the, to the cookouts
anymore. Jerry. Jerry's twisted.
Fuck. Yeah. Yeah. Um, one of
the things that Dawkins look,
get this guy spraying again. Let's
check. Oh, you know, acting up. Did we
join in? Wow. He's really beaten on
her man. Are they going to separate it?
Wow.
See what devil do you think you're doing?
He's drunk trying to grab the glass
and smell it while he's drunk.
Well, the grandmother thinks
that's funny. I'm just my own room.
The mother never been struck in
her whole life. Like go like,
Hi Dawn.
The grandmother's last time
I had to go,
come into my house and trying to tell
me what to do and hitting me. What?
Think of him parking. Tempt
you, but you're not, you're,
she didn't need to go there. She did. No,
she needed to get back to talking shit
about the guy being a clerk. Absolutely.
However, I forgot how much she
forgot how good she has a job.
He's got a good life.
That's so weird when you look at stuff
like that from another time and you go,
Whoa, that's not that
far ago. No. You know,
in terms of the amount of time
that human beings have been alive,
it's not that far. And in terms of
the life of the planet, you know,
obviously you get back further
and further and wider and wider.
It looks Tinier and Tinier. It's really
strange. Was that a guy getting spanked?
That's a girl. Wow. Wrestling.
They spank now she has
a very firm booty too,
but that was a fun spanking. This
guy's like, are not your baby.
Can't believe spanking my wife.
He's got to go back there
and why he's banging her.
She's going to close his eyes and
tell him about that guy spanking her.
That's so, wrestling is so silly. It's
such a silly, what are you talking about?
It's amazing. It's the best
thing we have. So it's so absurd.
It's pro wrestling, you don't mean real
wrestling weird, that real wrestling.
It's like one of the greatest fucking
sports, most difficult sports,
the world's ever known and super effective
in combat. But that fake wrestling.
So it's like there it is the uh,
front to American civilization.
It is the thing where if the aliens
come down and they turn on the TV of,
that's the first thing they watch.
You got a real problem on your hands.
And I get that. Like somebody
telling you, you know,
it's a soap opera for like basically
dude's yeah. And I'm like,
stop. I watch. I'm like, I like,
I almost, I understand the way
more for like a kid, you know,
the characters and all that stuff.
But yeah,
when I have adult friends,
I have a lot of adult friends that
all still watch it and love it.
Like Sam from opion,
Anthony fucking in love with it and
Tony Hinchcliffe and you're just like,
Hinchcliffe loves wrestling. He's one
of the biggest wrestler guys ever.
That is hilarious. I know
comic in Chicago, Marty Derosa
um,
fucking like talking about this shit.
Like did you see that shit?
What are you talking about man?
How could you even get into it? I don't
know. I don't know. And I tried. I think
if I can,
I realize that everybody has their,
maybe it's a nostalgia thing, maybe
it's because they liked it back then.
Maybe they don't smoke weed. That's
could be that they're all the classics.
Like I grew up with like Hulk Hogan and,
and all of them are like dead or retired.
So He's new guys. It's like I don't,
but I'm just saying like
the excitement I can,
I get the excitement for an 11 year old.
But like now when you have real sports,
and I love when the guys can,
they get real defensive like the guys
that are in it because they're always
doing their act no matter what
they're always doing. They're like,
you'll think the shit's real step
in the ring motherfucker. Okay.
Did you ever see,
see
John Stossel get beat up by the wrestler?
Yes, because he got, yeah. Yeah.
That's a classic.
This came up,
John Stossel gets beat up by wrestler key.
He got really fucked up.
He ruptured his here drum.
Yeah, and his hearing was,
and he had like long term
effects from that. Yeah. That
was a really not nice. No,
that he was getting a little
cocky with the guy. Sure.
He could have asked him in
a more respectful way. Well,
I'm not going into the ring to tell these
guys that. I think this shit's lame.
Who is the guy who beat him up?
I asked Dave Schultz, right guy,
it looks crazy. Little
Silo. Good business.
It was a good bit and I wouldn't be in it.
That one.
Why is it a good book called the
only the Tufts that's written.
You ain't anything and there's palm cove
when the camera right. He ain't need it.
Rednecks rednecks out here. I ain't
in it because it's a tough business.
That's terrific. Is that all you got?
I asked you if a standard questions,
standard questions. I think as this
fake, you're going to get spiked. Ah,
what the Hell's wrong with you? That's
open hand slap. Do you think it's like,
whoa.
The second one. The second one is
I think the one that did the wrong.
In all fairness, he was a
little mouthy. Yeah, sure.
There's a little mouthy with the
wrestler, you know? Why would you, uh,
is this a good business? First
of all, it says an interviewer.
That's a sucky interview.
If I interviewed a guy like that,
I would expect them to be upset with
me too. It was just a good business.
Why would you ask if it's a good business?
A horrible question.
Tell me about wrestling.
How'd you get involved in this?
Like how long you've been doing it.
How do you respond to people that
say that this is not real? Not me.
I'm not saying that you gotta be
nice to the guy. Don't be a dick.
I think it's fake. Yeah. It was like,
what are you, why are you so cocky?
Like why do you think you
could say that to a man?
Like inches in front of them just
in salt. What he does, it's all,
it's stupid and it fucking dope. It's,
it's a ranged, but it's not.
They're hitting each other for real.
They're slamming each other for real.
That angle, that guy took us those two.
Cause I also, I mean it just in life,
you always size up who's in the room.
Right. And like I think some
enormous dudes are fucking idiots,
but I'm not going to be like,
I think you're a fucking idiot to your
face cause I don't want to get my ear
fucking smashed.
It was not necessary to create drama
there that didn't draw anything out.
He had a different idea of how that
was going to turn out. He thought,
I'm going to ask him these questions and
make them look stupid because I'm way
smarter than this fucking clown.
Exactly. And then he got it. Exactly.
And you know, I mean he lived, he learned,
he's got a mustache and he's a white guy.
His name is Stossel and he's got a giant
Burt Reynolds style must and he still
has it. Does he really? He's had that shit
for that. Yeah. He hasn't shaved that.
He's still rocks that that's a fucked up
thing to happen to have a guy like Matt
handy like that in front of a camera.
And no one gives a shit.
No one does anything. Oh yeah. Everybody
moves. Everyone backing away from them.
No one's going to save you.
Right.
Then what are you going to do
that guys should enormous. Yeah,
because he's a giant man.
You've got a real problem,
Mr Stossel.
You're not being protected.
A lot of those guys are absolute scary
fucking. Of course they are. Yeah,
they were fucking huge because like Brock
Brock Lesnar, that's an enormous human.
Yeah. It's like I want to beat the fuck
out of you in front of the camera, man.
I mean, he might get arrested
for it eventually, but
like while it's going down,
like no one's going to help you.
That's just a fact.
It's sure the rock is a
beast to, oh, he's enormous.
He was bigger than ever
now. Yeah, he's huge now.
He's like really into bodybuilding.
He puts a lot of videos and tweets a lot
about like all the workouts, workouts.
He's doing it like four o'clock in the
morning lands, 5:00 AM he's at the hotel.
I saw a thing.
He said he's doing like two hours of
cardio and then three hours of that animal
is an animal total. And then he, uh,
he has cheat days that he puts online they
received but eats a hundred doughnuts,
doughnuts, giant stacks of brownies, jugs,
look several gallons of milk. I've seen
a lot of the like super athletes, uh,
post sugar,
like,
like a lot of like guys that are
doing like the super, you know,
cross training crossfit guys.
But their cheat thing is always
incredible amounts of sugar.
I think it's probably
cause a caloric intake.
Like they probably have an extreme
desire for heaven, caloric intake,
glucose kind of again, yeah, if you're
doing like crossfit and shit like that.
Plus also when you, you go with
like really healthy diet on the,
on a regular for the most part,
it's so tempting to go off the rails and
you still, you still gluten free. Yeah.
Yeah. How's that going? It's great.
I have no problems with it. Yeah,
I heard Udi bread is really good bread
to eat to try. So my try that out.
And then there's, uh, there's apparently
there's a gluten free bakery that sends,
one sends us, wants to send us some
stuff. Nice. That's in La, you know,
I don't miss it that much. I tried some
gluten free pasta and it tastes fine.
The big thing to me is I feel
way different after I eat.
When I would eat bread I'd be like,
ugh.
And I always assumed that that was just
how I felt after I ate because I always
ate bread.
I always had bread or pasta like always.
And then when it stopped
it was like, oh, like,
like I was being poisoned essentially,
you know, like hard holy, you know.
Is it hard to do gluten free when you
travel? Like is it harder to, it's harder,
but when I say poison,
obviously I'm being melodramatic.
But what I really mean is that your
body doesn't digest that shit. Well,
it takes a long time. It feels like
shit. It feels weird. And it's breads,
it's breads and pasta.
When you eliminate that stuff,
it eliminates a whole
level of after meal crash.
Like there's still a bit of an after meal,
slow down.
Like I want to have a big meal and then
go on stage for that very reason. Sure.
I wouldn't want to have a steak and
potatoes then run right on stage.
But the difference between a
steak and potatoes and steak,
potatoes and pasta is significant.
State potatoes and bread is significant.
That extra level of fucking
coma that you go into the pasta,
it's gone. That level's gone. I don't get
that level. And you still have potatoes?
Yeah,
you could have any carbs of rice.
It's the idea is all bait like it.
Some people say it's who we are and
it might be a little who we, you know,
it's psychosomatic. I'm
not, I don't think it is.
I think there's enough people that are
pointing to some research has been done
on it that it makes sense.
And there's also research done on
actual wheat itself that we'd itself
apparently in like the 1960s they altered
it and make it a little tougher so
they could survive pesticides and you
know, bug attacks and shit better.
And when they did that,
it made it much more difficult for people
to consume than the old school wheat
that people had been eating for
thousands of years. So essentially all,
I don't know shit about it. You're just
getting rid of wheat, right? Yup. Yeah.
That's it. Breads and even some alcohols
because it's a lot of alcohol years.
Yeah. But Not Heineken. Heineken,
which I drank anyway is uh,
is gluten free.
But like that's stuff that I love that
black Butte porter that's got tons of
gluten in it.
There's a lot of gluteny beers.
There's a lot of gluten in like things
like clam chowder has gluten in it.
It's a lot of stuff. Like you wouldn't
expect like powder you edge. I mean, you,
you're always reading about it now. Yeah.
I know what you can eat. Yeah. I just,
I just completely quit.
I just stepped back and said,
well, let's see if it's worth doing.
I'll do it. And if it's not worth doing,
if I don't feel any different at all,
I'll go right back. But you feel great.
But I feel a difference. There's
definitely a difference. Um,
there's a book called wheat belly
that I still haven't read, but, uh,
a lot of people point to that as being
a good source of information as to why,
uh, there was a, a, a change
in, uh, in wheat itself.
And what they're saying is that,
um,
whole grains in 2012 or not the whole
grains of 1950, the 19th century,
the Bible pre biblical times modern wheat
in particular is genetically distant
from its predecessors thanks to extreme
genetic changes inflicted on wheat and
the 1960s in the 1970s in the
name of increased yield per acre.
Oh,
okay.
So the healthy whole grains have been
repeatedly shown to reduce risk in
diabetes, heart disease and
colon cancer. It's true.
But if whole grains are compared
to process white wheat flour,
it's guilty of the kind of flawed logic
that dominates nutritional thinking,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Um,
so apparently the grain that people used
to eat is a much better tasting wheat
or a much better for you wheat,
but it just doesn't, it doesn't,
we don't have it anymore.
Wow.
Hmm. So eat a lot of protein
though. Yeah, I eat, um,
I almost all protein like fish or chicken
or meat or a and a lot of vegetables
and I still eat potatoes
and I'll still eat rice.
But there's a difference in the way
I feel. I just think digestion wise,
I think there's an issue with resources.
I think when you,
when you're eating wheat,
one thing that's happening is many more
resources that aren't used for other
things or use digest. It give,
must come down to like what it is.
When you think about a plate of Pasta,
chew that shit up, mash it up, swallow it,
and then pack it all together.
It's glue, you got glue,
you've got a big Wad of glue,
you know,
whereas your stomach acids are sort of
designed to digest other things like the
vegetables and meats. And I
think it's a grind man. I think,
and this is obviously coming from someone
who's nothing nutritionally sound,
I don't know what I'm talking about,
but I think it would just make sense.
And then once I noticed it, I
just, uh, he's still doing dairy.
Um, I tried to cut way back, but I
still like it. I like chocolate milk,
like ice cream too, but I cut back. But
it's still delicious when you don't,
I don't eat cereal anymore because
the gluten free cereals are not that.
You know what I mean? You
know, I like raisin bran.
I haven't found it gluten free raisin
brand so I don't even might exist but I
haven't found one yet.
So I stopped with my cereal.
I eat cereal like sometimes
late at night. It's like my, uh,
my cheat meal in front of the TV.
I get a big fucking boat.
Kellogg's raisin bran or yeah,
go off son.
I cut that shit out entirely so
I don't really have as much milk,
but there's a lot of um, like companies
now that is catered to the gluten free.
Right.
There's always new things coming out to
the milk and cookies or another one I
miss. Yeah. I used to get these
uncle Eddie Vegan, whatever
the fuck it is. Cookies.
Is that what it is? I'm glad he's, I
think he's Vegan cookies from whole foods.
They're so good. Peanut butter and
chocolate chip. It listened to me.
If you're still eating gluten, don't,
don't, you know, don't pass up on these.
Please go get them because they're
the most delicious thing ever.
These vegan chocolate chip cookies,
the oatmeal chocolate chip
with a cold glass of milk.
I would eat those until I felt sick.
Trader Joe's trader Joe's made a crazy,
I tried to choke up really good. They're
so good. I don't know why they're not.
They don't tell us bad cause
they're vegan and he's fine.
Is there a gluten free version?
Well I think Vegan just lacking the eggs.
I don't know what they bind it with,
but is there one that you can get?
I haven't seen one yet.
I've seen chocolate chip
cookies that are gluten free.
They were pretty good. Pretty good.
They can't fuck with those oatmeal,
chocolate chip cookies.
Those were incredible.
I would go pick them all over non Vegan
ones. Yeah. That's how good they are.
Yeah, I've had, I always thought that
for me, the Tj ones were amazing.
I would sit in front of the TV,
like say if I was watching
a really good movie and I,
we need a whole bag of
those fuck healings.
It was probably several thousand calories.
A giant glass of milk. I love. Um,
I, there's so many times
have just been decadent,
but when you hear about how many calories,
some people can consider like
a Michael Phelps type dude,
that's just so fucking awesome.
I want to watch him while he's training.
Watching. Yes. Yes, I
do. I went and saw, yeah.
I mean they said to me like, uh, you
know, workouts are so intense. Yeah.
Is like get going.
First thing of the day
might be a few bacon, egg
and cheese sandwiches. Yeah.
And then like everything goes
down. It's like, all right,
you're in the pool and it's just
training, training, training.
It's get out and you eat like a
bowl of pasta. Like, you know,
that's enough to fill five
people's stomachs, you know? Yeah.
I think he probably blows off so much
insane energy. Yeah. It's not even, yeah,
it's got to be kidding.
Wrap your head around that.
What kind of shits this
guy taken for real?
It was feed thunder is all the time.
Number six, it's gotta go somewhere.
It's gotta be number six is what's the
number six on the Bristol stool chart?
What is the stool chart? It's
how they rate, uh, your shit's.
So one through seven one and two
are like you're grinding them out.
Like they're pretty difficult.
Most of my shifts are not impressive,
but every now and then I will give birth
to Godzilla. Well, is it a nice slider?
Oh yeah, that's a four sliders or for,
even if it's giants, that's what you want.
Even if it's giant. And if
five, six, six is really sloppy,
lots of little pieces blew it out
your ass. Yeah. And that happens.
Seven is all liquid.
No. And that was, are these bad or good?
On a scale of one, three and fours,
that's what you want. Three and four.
Three and four is where it's at.
We have forest one, three and
four. I'll tell you what, man.
A really good shit that you've held
in for a while is incredibly pleasing.
Oh yeah.
You've been holding it in and all of
the in far I've got to get this all out.
I gotta get to get,
got to get into until I had file.
Even if you're in a public
bathroom, you sit down, you just uh,
ah.
And it's so good that it doesn't bother
you that you're taking a shit in a
public bathroom. You just unload
that dragon right out of your ass,
swims out and destroys.
There's really no feeling like
it really no feeling like it.
Those are fun though cause it's
like your butthole sneezing
the seven one with the blood.
It's the word that's one with a
blood is seven Evans, blood sevens,
just all liquid,
no solid
material. The thing is, do you ever have,
when you hold it in and you know it's
going to be a five or six like you ever
have like a,
for me it's like if you have too greasy
breakfast and it's the first thing that
enters your stomach and
you know when you get up,
like if you're at a restaurant
you're like, this is gonna,
this is gonna be unbelievable in the next,
whenever,
whenever I could find a place to sit down,
this is going to be a disaster.
And then you get, if you're in a hotel,
you get up to your room and it is like a,
like a religious experience.
Yeah.
I had a recently had a gluten free vegan
cheese pizza and just the vegan cheese
doesn't digest in your body. Your bias
is like, what do you want from me?
And then just like the next
day it was like asteroids,
fireballs and it rains weren't coming
out even though it wasn't even spicy
cheese. It was just because it was
vegan shoes stung a little bit. Yeah,
it'll be stingers.
Ooh,
we'll base thing. Or is it your beautiful
here? You need to go to a doctor.
You know that, right? I told you
this before, just for your mind,
not even for your bud.
Then I've actually talked to said they
just go to too many of you out there in
the world. It's nothing I could
do. They got a full [inaudible].
Everything's perfect. Everything's
perfect. Speaking of crazy doctors,
a Nigerian guy, uh,
working on, it's a college,
this college paper on the leader,
he proved that gay marriage
is impossible with magnets.
This is the single dumbest
thing anybody has ever seen.
It's amazing. This isn't
a hoax. This isn't the,
I don't know if you go to
death and tax mag, um, I think,
I don't think that's a legit website,
but this is, no, I think this is real.
I think this is totally real because
every other story, she was real so dumb.
Okay. This, I can't
even say the guy's name.
She Bouley heme.
I'm a la Ha.
A postgraduate student at the University
of Lagos in Nigeria has finally
discovered a way to
increase in convertible.
He proved that gay marriage is wrong
using a variety of scientific techniques
like magnets. And this sounds
promising. This is what he said.
This is in quotes to start with. Physics
is one of the most fundamental level,
the sciences.
And I used to bar magnets in my research.
Hey Bob magnet is it horizontal magnet
that has the North Pole and the South
Pole. And when you being to buy magnets
and you bring the North Pole together,
you will find the two north poles
do not attract. They will repel.
So
you pushed him away from showing that
a man should not attract that mine
showing that a man should
not attract the men.
If he bring to south both together,
you will find that the two south poles
will not attract indicating that they
same sex, mad at shooting,
not hold. A female,
should not attract female as the south
pole of the magnet does not attract a
south pole of I back that
brilliant, brilliant, hilarious.
It's got actually wrote this stuff down.
Maybe he's trolling,
maybe he's gay as fuck.
He's slinging Dick like he's handing
out Churros at affair and he's just,
and he's just like, listen,
I know what to do here.
I just tell them that it's no game
adage I went with telling me you want
attracted to a Dick,
suck on my Dick.
I do not believe is sucking up on my Dick.
I can't even believe you put a 10
to like this. I have to change too.
Stuck up on my Dick. I will come in your
mouth, but only this one time he uh,
he should hold a press conference. This
guy just so people can be like, ah,
I'm attracted to, I'm smelly armpits.
Which magnet can you show me?
We'll just prove my hard on.
Yeah.
Isn't that a thing with like a lot
of gay dudes there until like stinky.
I got something for you. Gay
dudes. Borys Tommy Button's red.
Yeah.
Did you ever get attacked or picked on
or rather a hit on by getting hit on
gays? Sure. What did they do to you?
What's the number one move do you think?
First of all, we offended. Do you like
it? I don't look that gay. No, no.
I wasn't offended. I mean, um, I've been,
I've been so hit on that I'm like,
I really feel bad for women.
Like it puts it in perspective,
you know? Oh, right, right. Yeah.
Like she has a real pig man. Like
I'm not a piece of meat. Jesus.
I had a comic corner me once and
get really goofy with me. Yeah.
I had Montreal drunk
and it was so vile icon.
A totally understood like what it must
be like for a woman to get hit up by some
sleazy dude's sleazy guy. Had A sleazy
guy do it too. And he was like, uh, what?
What did he say? He goes, he was,
he was a comic and he's bringing
me on stage and he had been like,
that's a good shirt on you and all that,
you know, all those little comment.
I was like, all right man. And then
he was like, when I bring you up,
and I could tell he was hammered. What
if I kiss you on the mouth? I'll be like,
don't do that dude. He was like, all
right. All right. I want to like,
oh my gosh, don't do
that. A comic on stage.
He lick the mic off
before it gave it to you.
I'm hoping that some of his
saliva we'll get in yours.
No, he was just like, he was a
creep. Right. So I was like, that's,
that's what a creepy dude is. To want
to name names. No, don't do it. Okay.
What if it's the same guy? It could be.
What's the same? The name of the guy?
I can't, don't do it. I don't want it. No.
Brad's got the camera on now.
Oh No, no, no, no.
People like his forensic with that
I made up.
Don't worry about it folks.
You want to hear that
something better than that.
I was in a restaurant the other
day. This is not even gay. Oh, okay.
This is just disgusting. Okay. A woman,
uh, nothing to do with Gavin. He and say,
why is scarier than that woman
brought in a dog, a giant dog,
like a lab.
Right.
And she sat down at a restaurant and the
of the labs sat down next to our table
and I go, what the fuck's going
on? And the waitress told her,
told me that she has an
emotional needs dog. Oh yeah.
Yeah. Did you know about this?
Absolutely. Tom. Tom got it. Yeah.
You got an emotional needs
talk and I might get it to
take it on the airplane for free. Get
the fuck out of here. Wait a minute.
So if you have an emotional needs dog,
like say if you get your dog and
emotional needs talking license,
you could take that dog on an airplane for
free. For free. For free. Yes, for free.
But for a small,
every airline has like a different policy.
I mean like what if someone's a massively
allergic to dogs are sitting in front
of you.
I have a new dog as dirty clown,
like fucking dogs get on planes
where I was like, this is a joke,
right? Like a Basset Hound and and
so the phone, we were all like,
what's going on? Like the same thing.
We were on a plane and they were like,
it's their fucking emotional needs
dog and emotional needs done.
And I've seen, I've seen a, uh,
what's it called? An English bulldog,
you know, like a big bulldog.
Uh, get on. Same thing.
Like it's emotional
needs dog is incredible.
I couldn't imagine that it would
be legal in a restaurant though.
That is so crazy because actually one
that has an outside patio and she wasn't
even using the outside patio really?
This dog. Right? Pretty Open asshole.
It's just sitting there in the middle
of the dining room. Yeah. Yeah.
Not Washed. No. I mean
the dog takes shits.
Tony's hosing his ass off before they
bring them out in public and make it
presentable. He's just farting right
in front of everybody of Said lab man.
It was a lap dog. Golden
Lab. Yeah. Crazy bitch. Yeah.
And uh, I think, did you tweet this?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. It was a notable person.
Famous person. A famous woman. That's
funny. Ridiculous broken bitch.
I can't bring a fucking dark.
That is so it's so rude to bring a big
dog into a restaurant like that and act
like you're king shit and just sit there
with the dog and pat it like that idea
of emotional needs dog. It's
so crazy. It's so crazy.
The problem is,
look,
there are people that are absolutely
devastated and there are probably people
that if it wasn't for the dog, they
probably wouldn't even want to be alive.
There are is a fact that that that thing
really applies to where it's very, yeah.
Guess what? You don't get it to bring
your dog in a fucking restaurant.
Doesn't matter.
Don't get it.
Bring that big stupid hairy animal into
a restaurant and then someone touches
something that your dog's butt touched
and they get worms because I easily could
happen.
You don't know if your dog has worms.
You don't know what the
fuck's going on there.
You barely take care of that thing.
How many checkups you give her a dog.
God can't even talk.
It's accounts that paranoid though.
You're going to be more as paranoid. Just
opening the door to go to the bathroom.
Not about paranoid due
to have dogs in my own.
You just don't bring your dogs near a
fucking dinner table. It's that simple.
When you're,
you're out there at a restaurant.
The dog is literally at the tail
putting his face on the table.
The person's eating and
the dogs right here.
She's touching it and then
she's touching the table.
She's rubbing the dog's hand
and she's picking up the forks.
She's mean she's a dirty bitch
and that if she wants to do that,
I don't do that at home.
I don't allow my dogs to fucking sit right
near that off my ice cream cone. Well,
you're an idiot. That's a dumb thing.
You probably have toxoplasma. Oh,
but you, you know, if people
want to do that at home,
they choose to do that at home.
That's one thing.
But if you have that dog around where
other people eat inside a building, it's,
there's a reason why everybody can't do
it. Yeah. She just wants her dog with her.
Yeah. Well, there's a reason why
everybody can't do it because this,
that if it was totally sanitary,
anybody would be allowed to do it.
We wouldn't even care.
The reason why it's not allowed it's
cause it's unsanitary. Right. So to,
to put other people's
health concerns, oh, uh,
behind your need to be with a fucking
thing that loves you all the time is
incredibly selfish.
Yeah.
To bring that into a restaurant and
know that you are violating the standard
health procedures with a loophole and
those health procedures were put in place
to make sure that people don't get sick
from other people's dirty ass, stinky.
Dot. What about, what about when
it's a service dog? What do you know?
The person needs it, but it's still
a dirty, it's a, it has a problem.
It makes more sense at least. But it's
still that dog still there. It's still is.
Well,
the,
I think they should take precautions
and the people that work there should
probably clean up extra good anywhere
around the animal. But if I get,
you're a blind person. Yeah, I hear Ya.
It makes sense. But this is not, not that,
this is just the needy, crazy California.
It's California. That's California Ed.
Crazy famous people.
California is the first.
I remember when I moved
here and I started,
I was getting like postproduction jobs
working in different places, right.
And Stat people on staff from the,
uh,
post production supervisor or to
a producer, a writer to editors.
There were fucking like 11
dogs, right? The first one,
I was like, what is going on?
And it was like, well, you know, we
bring our dogs to work. And I was like,
I've never seen this
anywhere where people just,
and then every place I got a Gig
after that always had 10 fucking dogs.
And they were like, well, yeah, I mean
people just bring their dogs to work.
I used to bring my dog to news
radio. Yeah. Frank Sinatra.
The pit bull is to bring him to work.
And I used to bring squeaky squeaky
Fromme my other pit voice to bring her to
fear fat. It's a caliph. It's California.
Yeah. Squeaky. Fromme it was creepy.
A little bitch. I couldn't leave her
at home with the other dogs. Oh really?
She would start some shit. What's, what
kind of dog was it as a pit bull? Hippo.
So I'd bring her with me to work. Good dog
though. Oh she was sweetie with people.
Yeah. She was a real sweetie
with people. She loved people.
She hated other dogs though she didn't
like them because they would take
attention away from her.
She was a rescue dog and there's a great
thing about rescuing dogs and that you
get to save a dog from, you
know, most likely being put down.
But the bad thing about rescue
dogs is like when I got her,
she was almost a year, she had been
really badly abused and so that,
that almost a year of her life
she had been treated like shit.
And when I came along and
treated her with love,
anybody that got between that
was like very dangerous to her.
Like another dog that came
in and tried to get the love,
like she would snap at the cat, like she
put it, get the fuck away from my man.
Like she wanted only me to pet her and
when she would come running with the
other dogs,
she would growl at them and snap at them
to get out of the way so that she could
get pat back. Everybody else off.
Yeah. Yeah. She was just gangster.
And were you able to never let it
all out? No, she killed my dog.
She killed one of my dog, just she really,
she actually killed two of them. Yeah,
she killed one of the dogs and then she
got in a fight with a male and to the
point where he had to be put down.
Oh my God. Yeah. She was crazy there.
They're crazy dogs. The problem with
pit bulls is you're dealing with,
and people who get mad at
me for saying this, listen,
nobody loves those dogs more than I do.
I've had a few them in my life
and frank was an amazing dog.
He was a beautiful, smart,
a sweetheart with people,
with all my friends who was so kind.
He was since you like sweet, friendly,
loving dog, but he was a Hawaiian boar
fighting dog. Like they will use him,
use him to hunt bores and those dogs were
so animal aggressive because they were
bred to go after bores and hold onto them.
There was so smart because of that.
They were like really clever and
they'd have really high prey drive.
And a lot of times in
dogs high prey drive, uh,
is also with high intelligence.
Like a lot of those dogs that get through,
especially because the cruel nature
of both dogfighting and using them for
animals,
for hunting and stuff like that.
Like you have to have like only
the best, wildest, craziest,
strongest bravest dog to breed. And that's
how you make like a strong bloodline.
So the real problem is like they're,
they're bred to do shit
you don't want them to do,
they're bred to fight their
bread, dig, want to kill
animals. Right? So it's, it's,
even if you're really
good at training them,
which I was really good at training dogs.
I've been training dogs my whole life.
I'm pretty good at it. I mean, I'm not a
professional, I'm not like a, you know,
guys who trained dogs for Schudson,
but I'm pretty good at getting a dog to
explain what I want and I know not to be
cruel to them and always give them love.
And when you get a new puppy,
spend more time with the big dog than
you do with the puppy to let the big dog
know that the little dogs around,
you're going to get more attention,
you're going to get more attention. Like
I'm good at that shit, but they, you know,
they have a nature,
they have a nature from thousands of
years at breeding and it's really hard to,
to change. It's really hard.
It's just the wiring, right?
Like it's just not going to a bit,
I mean certainly you can develop dogs
that are more aggressive because you're
promoted,
but I did the opposite of promoting it.
I tried to discourage
it whenever possible.
I'm trying to encourage love whenever
possible and like make them be sweeties
get getting plenty of exercise.
I bought a big yard just because I have
plenty of room for them to run around.
And want them to be contained.
It doesn't matter.
They want to fuck up other dogs
and she's still one of the kills.
They wanted to go to war, so fight to
the death, you know? Yeah. It's crazy.
But there's meanwhile she's slept
in my bed. Sweetest dog ever. Damn.
She's my baby.
You know,
she would go on trips with me and she
would sit right right beside me and my car
seat. Like if I drove somewhere, I
would take her with me all the time.
It took her to work all the time.
She would sit right next to me,
just big stupid face, head out the window.
And that's awesome. Dogs are amazing.
I love dogs, but you can't bring me
the restaurant. You fucking crazy.
Can't have that dog dirty ass hole out
there with my little kids are touch and
shit.
One side of the restaurant is a dog.
They'll sides of three year old with a
vulnerable immune system and your dirty
stinky ass hall.
Do you bring
dog out me? Yeah. No I don't.
I take my dog to restaurants,
but I'm more concerned about
just fucking restaurants.
These waiters and with their dirty
poop hands. Fucking tough. I mean,
I worked in restaurants, so I saw shit
like, like, oh, that guy pissed me off.
I might take his hamburger patty, put it
against my balls and put it back on it.
I saw that shit all the time. Oh fuck.
I've done it a few times. I've seen,
how dare you,
you should lie about that.
It's been seven years is that statue
of limitation is legally people put on
their balls. Oh Dude, I
there. That's horrible.
I did this one where this guy kept on
and he said he wanted a medium rare steak
and so I gave him a medium, right? It
was perfect. He goes, that's too raw.
And I'm like,
do you even know what a medium rare steak?
And so we brought it back medium
and then he came. It's like, oh,
you overcooked it. I was like, all
right, you didn't know anything.
So like when they gave us the stake back,
I just wiped it all over my ass hole
and then put it back on the plate.
And then you fed it all? Oh yeah. Wow.
Brian route all of your asshole.
What'd your asshole feel like?
I think he lost there. The
guy didn't even know. I mean,
well you had state juice all over your
ass hot steak on your ass. Yes I did.
You're a problem.
Didn't someone that seasoning kind of
give it a little kick and it tastes like
suck. They know you can't even
taste them with your asshole. Yeah,
but you know we're on that thing.
Definitely a thing where when
you're a waiter and and the the,
the table is treating you like shit.
It's like, you know, fuck you dude.
I don't give a fuck at that. The, you
know, I'm working at this restaurant,
how you're talking to me right now.
And so you'll see there's,
that happens more than ever. That's why
like when you can play it at restaurants,
unless you're cool about it,
you got to watch the fuck out because
it's a lot of people do crazy shit.
Yeah, no doubt. No doubt.
I think that restaurants,
like when I go and I tried to
be like super nice to everybody,
I'm super cognizant of that. You don't
want to treat somebody like shit.
It's about to handle your food. You
gotta be careful about that, man. Yeah.
I've seen people do things.
I worked at a restaurant and I saw a dude
spit and someone's a ice cream shake.
It took a big Haka Louie
and stuck it in that Oh man,
and for no reason, he just decided
to be cute. He thought it was cute.
He would be tried to be funny.
I was working as a dishwasher and he was
working as a cook and he would go and
spit on the cheeseburgers and shit
and flip up. That's fucked up, man.
He was going to watch this.
Jesus Christ,
the restaurant I worked at,
and there was a bandaid that was in
the tomato basil soup and one of the
waiters,
waitresses brought it back and it's like
somebody put a bandaid in the soup and
I just remember they
never replaced the soup.
They just got her more
soup from the same thing
it was in.
I was in this one place in Hawaii and
these people were trying to scam the
waiter. They were trying to scam the
waiter by saying that the waiter has to do
something about, you know, their bill
because the rice was too hot for like,
first he brought the rice over,
it was cold,
then you bring it over and
it's so hot it burns her mouth.
I mean you guys got to get it together
here and like they were being like,
it was an English guy.
He was being loud and belligerent.
It was so bad and so blatant and it
was almost like he was doing like some
undercover camera, like showing
how someone could scam a waiter.
And so then the guy brings
over the, uh, the uh,
the manager of the restaurant, you know,
he insists on speaking to the manager.
Like he feels like,
like by the time the manager gets there,
the manager just wants to calm everything
down. Can we comp your meal sir?
And they're working on trying to get the
meal comps so you can tell the manager
knows this guy's full of shit. Of
course. So he like lets the guy talk out.
But the guy was,
he didn't even try to calm
him down whether God was
talking like really loud in
this restaurant.
So it became a really strange thing
where like everybody was like paying
attention to it. It was theater, but
the manager just stayed calm like, sir,
what are you trying to do? Like, what
would you like? And the guy's like, well,
I'm saying you guys have got to
make amends here. This, this,
this rice was cold and now it's so
hot. She burned her mouth. Like,
I almost burned my mouth. And
he's like, and you know you,
you didn't have one of the specials on
the menu. I go to order it. You're out.
My good man, you know, I'm from London.
If this happens in London, you know,
they do something about it. And
the guy said, what are you just,
what are you suggesting sir? He goes,
well, I'm suggesting that you, you know,
take care of our bill or some something
along those lines. And the guy's like,
this is not going to happen.
Sorry.
And another waiter comes over and then
they're just hovering over this guy while
he pretends to like be outraged about
this. He's trying to put together a scam.
He just doesn't have any ammunition,
but they're going for it and see
countless times at comedy clubs so
many times at comedy clubs. Oh yeah.
Mock indignation. And
there's, it's always like,
it's like a lingering group like people
or have left the show and you're like,
what's going on there? Why are they
here? Right. And they're like, man,
this shit wasn't even good
food. You brought, you ate it
and like, yeah, but it was,
it was bad. Like you ate
it, you didn't say anything.
Then they just order a shitload to like,
they always ordered like three appetizers
or like they just go crazy and then at
the end they tell you, I've seen
it, I've seen it. A restaurant,
a guy with a big party, the shrimp
are terrible man. These were bad.
Like the ones that you ate
an hour ago. Yeah. This, this
has got to go, man. I can't,
I mean,
you know,
there's another problem too that people
do and that's when [inaudible] go out.
No,
a bunch of people go out and one person
gets stuck paying the majority of the
bill. Like a lot of people don't
chip in and then they start going,
well what the fuck man? And then
then people will start complaining,
well this wasn't even going good.
I've seen that happen so many times where
people don't pay their share or they
conveniently ignore the fact that the
check has gone there and start getting up
and grabbing their keys. They don't even
act like they're going to contribute.
Like I've seen that happen many times
where people like one person shells in
like 20 and then a while mom put,
I'll put in 40 but mine was
only 20 and then there's like,
well then he put it 40 shit. I don't
have to put in anything. Right?
Like people have all got weird
logic when it comes to paying a bill
that happens every night going to norms,
you know all the comics,
like 20 comics all sitting
there and you're like, wait
a second. I gave 40 bucks.
Why didn't you know that's not
good all the time came for it.
Half the time nowadays
where I was planning on,
you know, everyone chipping in
something, I'm like, I really,
I have to bust out credit card
and pay a crazy amount more.
Yeah,
yeah.
That,
that can become a problem and it also
becomes a problem if they expect you to
pay. Like if you pay a couple
of times they're like, yeah,
red panel pay and then to start
order ordering omelets and shit.
Hashbrowns and like, yeah, I
wasn't going to get orange juice,
but fucking red bands going to Brian.
He's got my back.
I was going to have some ice water, but
I'm pretty sure red man is going to pay.
I'll get that. Steak and eggs. Yeah.
I just throw it down to 20 at
that point where it's as easy,
like $5 more than I should. It'd
be all right. Here's my, you know,
you have to do that every year.
You can see people doing that though if
you're around long, especially comics.
So opportunistic man,
the struggling comic is one of the
sleaziest most least trustworthy animal in
all of entertainment because they're like
park criminal part artists all wrapped
up together. Like how many struggling
comics do we know that early?
Just a hair from being a criminal.
Yeah. Well they're homeless people.
They all live in their cars. There's
a lot of that. Hollywood hills.
You always take care of shit though.
Like I've been turned down to pay stuff
by you every time I've ever. Yeah.
But that's when we're working together.
That's what, when we work together,
I take care of everything.
That's the deal.
Does it really take care of all the hotel?
I take all the meals. Awesome. Carol.
But it's, uh, I think the way you're
supposed to deal with it, you know,
it's not your job to be there with me. You
know, your job is to do your show. Yeah.
So all the other time,
all the other stuff during the day,
like that takes away from you the
amount of money that you make it a Gig.
You know,
if you have to worry about paying all
your meals and paying for our hotel and
paying for this, for paying for that,
that seems just like bullshit to me.
Like know when you're on the road, you
know you're my guest. That's nice. I have,
it's very nice. Yeah. I,
I have friends that I've brought on
the road who assume that I'm in that
position to really, I didn't bring, I'm
like, yeah, you know, I got you this week.
And then like they were just like,
let's go out to eat, let's say no.
And then the bill comes in and you're
like, Hey man, uh, yours was 50 bucks.
What do you want to do? I don't have 53
days. And what do they, what do you say,
bitch? Yeah, I mean, you know, certain
point you're just like, all right,
I'm not going to make a fucking scene
out of it unless it were like real
significant. I'm just like,
all right man, good date.
So they just assume that you were going
to pay. I've had that happen for sure.
That's hilarious. Of course it doesn't
seem like something would be normal.
In fact,
one of the reasons why I chose to do
that from the get go was all the people
that would complain about like being on
the road with someone and how much money
it would cost. Oh right. Yeah, yeah.
And we've got to pay for all my meals.
So like at the end of the day I don't
make any money and I'm like, yeah,
you know why you don't make any money
cause you can't even eat your food.
Do you have at home? You know you got
to eat out every meal. Right. You know,
and there's, you know, there's no
reason for that. I think if you,
if a guy's doing well,
did you see about that guy is just
not a comic but there's a guy,
it was a video as a clip
we played on my podcast.
On your mom's house. How
the guy who's like get your
hands off my penis. That guy,
that guy. My Dad. So my dad
is that your hands off my
peanut. This guy, if you look
at this guy, he, he does is,
he's doing exactly
what we're talking about.
He became famous for this in Australia,
which is he would go out to five star
meals like in restaurants and then when
the bill came he would just go, I don't
have any money. And they were like,
what? And He'd be like, I just
don't have any money. Like I'm,
I don't have any money.
And most of the time they didn't want
to create scenes in these places so he'd
get thrown out sometimes he would fake
a heart attack and like he's like, ah,
and they call an ambulance.
So the priority was on
getting him to a hospital.
He became like the most famous guy for
doing this to the point where he had
multiple court appearances and
like judges would like, you know,
be like you're a disgrace to
humanity and the way this is such a,
and he'd be like, I'm a
terrible person. I know
it's one of the funniest
videos in the world.
This is him out of coming
out of a restaurant,
manifests,
he's fighting against the cops.
Got me on the penis.
Penis.
I love how it ends.
Farewell
Guy was for the hundredth time.
They all knew him.
That's what was going on there. They're
like, you're the same fucking asshole.
What a crazy fuck.
What if you ran a restaurant?
What a pain in the ass to
guy like that would be,
takes advantage of every other
people being nice in the rules.
And he would also order like
extraordinary bottles of wine. Yes.
I'm this horse and then he put the course.
You probably also runs red lights.
It's not for me. It's for you. Chess
master. He is. He was, he's dead. Yes.
Really?
What's his name?
Um. Oh that guy died. Yeah, he's
died. Um, I don't mind. I don't know.
Three, I think his last
name. I think it was dos.
D. O. U. Z. A. D. O. U. Z. I think so. Um,
and they think he might've been, you know,
mentally ill as well. Know what Robert?
Hey, it kind of reminds me of
Robert. It's Dope D'souza. Okay.
D s o u. S a Hungarian guy. Yeah.
In Australia. Yeah. That was his,
that was his suck you in Chinese male
suck Chinese bill by them peanuts.
I think that's the man.
Me and Tommy are going to be on the road.
Hold on a second. Let's figure this out.
You know that's not there man. I'm man,
I'm coming up the wrong name.
Wrong name. Yeah. That's not him.
What does it say on that video?
You just play Brian Mann.
Australian man.
Get your hands off my penis,
man.
That's not the guy.
MMM.
Not,
not the Souza.
Just sit as Australian man.
Oh, here it is. I'll see the guy there.
Yeah. Just it doesn't say in any of the
videos on youtube at least that I see.
Okay.
Um, I've, I see the video on live leak
item info.
Get your hands off my pay.
Nice.
Hmm.
So apparently he was a chess master.
Yeah.
Paul here. Paul Dozo,
right? Yeah. Paul Paul.
Charles doza dubbed the restaurant runner.
He was a chess master. Wow. Check night.
A former chef who dines at expensive
restaurants and then pleads poverty has
been convicted for the 54th time
of refusing to pay for a meal.
Can Paul Charles Dozer, he
was only 48. They're dub.
The restaurant runner by local newspapers
was fined $180 on Monday for refusing
to pay a $50 bill at a Chinese restaurant.
The following day he dined out.
He dined out at the five star,
Sheraton Wentworth hotel.
Then told the staff that he could
not pay the $48 check. He was fine.
$200 for that offense on Wednesday and
order to compensate the restaurant.
Dozer pleaded guilty,
but the charge is saying that he
was in a state of inebriation.
Hmm Huh.
He was a Hungarian master chess player
and the leading junior drawing with
portage,
et Cetera,
in between and in depth bracken.
I don't even know how to say this.
In 1956
wow. This says that, um, he
sometimes he would eat, drink,
say he was very ill, ask for an
ambulance to be called out of concern.
They would take him.
But then one night he was caught when
the same ambulance driver picked him up.
If I am a different restaurant,
um, oh, that's so funny.
And he sometimes rented a luxurious
apartment paying advanced rent,
hired expensive furniture,
I guess rented that,
sold the furniture and then disappeared.
Wow. Yeah. There's people that
don't play by the rules man,
and there's people that are just fucking
crazy to like, who knows? I mean,
this guy easily could have
been some sort of a sociopath.
It could have been just completely nuts.
It's funny though that someone would
be a chess master and that would be
something that would be into doing. Can
I get the check night? I mean, it really,
if you can deal with the actual shame
of being told that you're, you know,
you're the delinquent and you're not
paying. If you can deal with that,
you just got an amazing meal that you
can never afford and you just keep doing
it over and over again. It doesn't bother
you in the slightest. Oh yeah. You don't.
I saw a, that's fucking hilarious.
The world's end. Oh yeah.
Simon pub crawl. Simon Pegg. Yeah.
Yeah. Fucking funny movie, Dude.
Fuck. Those guys are all integrated
together. That was his best one.
I like Shaun of the dead. Shaun of
the dead was good. This was better.
This was really fucking funny. It was
really good, man. It was interesting.
It's like, I don't want to say
too much. I don't to give it away,
but it's like two different movies.
It's like you're watching one movie and
then also in the movie changes sort of
like when dusk till dawn. You remember
in the beginning of dusk till dawn,
like super like serious,
like the action thriller and then it
becomes as Wacky, Zany vampire movie.
This is not quite as extreme,
but very a very two,
two very distinctly different films
and fucking great man. It's great.
I really enjoy the shit. I laughed out
loud like really hard a couple of times.
And then the theater right now. Yes.
Yes, it's right. It's right now.
I laughed like really good stuff, man.
I really liked him. I liked the
other guy to the big guy. Oh,
the big guy was amazing. He
steals the movie. He's a big
guy. The Shit. Yeah. Yeah.
It was incredible. Man is incredible
and they're always together.
Those two make a lot of movies together,
right?
They're always doing stuff
together. Yeah. Yeah, they did.
They did. Shaun of the dead was
the one they did with the, um,
it was like hot fuzz. Fuzz. Yeah. That's
when there was like the killer. Right.
Until I love that. I love
all of those. Yeah. Shot Him.
My Dad's one of my favorite movies. He,
yeah, he's a bad motherfucker. The guy.
It's just funny. He's just
funny. I mean, his sensibilities,
he's just really good at being funny.
Yeah. You know, for whatever reason.
What's funny though, when I put
it on Twitter, everybody was like,
don't you mean this is the end, right?
Like the, the same, it's really similar.
So Seth Rogan, they're like correcting
me and I'm like, no, fuck heads. Yeah.
I wouldn't say that also
though. Yeah. That looks good.
I heard good things about that. I
would see any of that. It looks good.
James Franco, was that right? Yeah.
James frightened. They have like, uh,
a lot of cameos in that. Oh
yeah. Yeah, a lot. Well, I mean,
Craig Robinson, that whole crew with
Jonah Hill, Michael, uh, Michael Cera,
like all the guys that you've
seen in those movies separately,
all make appearances, I think. Why
are so many chess players crazy.
I was just thinking about that. Somebody
show up, put up a photo of Bobby Fischer,
he and he's nuts. Oh my God.
Crazy racist too, right? Uh,
anti-semite like big time and it
takes that one. What's that about?
She just had a whole thing about like,
he hated Jews and then
they've found out that he was,
uh, actually part Jewish
Jewish and origin. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. So he's trying to throw him off the
tracks. You'll be like, how Ted Haggard,
we talk bad about gay people.
Yeah. But he wasn't like,
he wasn't the older he got,
I think the crazier Fisher got,
he wasn't even subtle about it,
man. He was very much like, well,
you know what I think is also an issue
with a guy like Bobby Fisher that he's
just so fucking smart and so crazy.
Too smart for his own good.
If you ever seen those videos,
Brian,
see we can pull this up where Bobby
Fischer would play multiple games of chess
simultaneously.
He would walk in a room and they would
all be playing and he would walk down the
aisle and make his moves at like 16
different tables at the same time and then
just Kinda,
he's playing them all in his head at
the same time he was playing them all.
He had an all the games calculated up
in his head running simultaneously.
All he did was chess. Man, that hurts or
is it for an era? It hurts my deck. Yeah.
I feel it in my deck
and a tip to the base.
That's too much work on craziness.
When I see someone who just completely
engulfed by something like that,
that's just like a some super master
that's completely engulfed in something
like chess kind of freaks me out.
Yeah, it's scary. It freaks me out.
I don't know where the Ma, I searched
for multiple chess games. Probably fish.
That's not it because you don't,
you don't watch the actual game itself.
You Watch him walking into a room and
he's playing all these games at the same
time. There's a great
documentary about him, doesn't,
he did look up multiple
simultaneous pool games.
I put Bobby Fischer multiple
chats games. He, um,
who like took him in and in the end I
think it was like Iceland or something.
Iceland. Someone did write. Somebody
gave him, yeah. Okay. Casbar off.
We'll pull up Casbar off. You
could find him doing it. Um,
Caspar off simultaneous chess game.
There's a Casbar off walking in the room.
He's another super genius and it's
like a gang of people here. Oh yeah.
It's crazy,
man.
This guy just walking down this
huge table when all these geniuses,
they have notebooks and pencils and shit.
They're all studying each move and
kiss bar off, walks in and like,
literally within seconds he's made a
move. Look at this. Boehm Bitch. You Dad,
you're fucked. Here. Me. Fuck
that. Well, you got to do
here. You Ain't gonna do shit,
bitch. Suck on that. Oh, you can go
fuck yourself. And how about oh bitch,
you crazy. Oh, I see what you're doing.
Bam. Slam. Checkmate socket. Wow.
This is like dozens of people.
He's playing insane. Yeah,
thank is bar off would just do
this on a regular basis. I mean,
look at a couple tables of people.
Three huge long tables of people and he
looks over each chessboard no more than
15 seconds. He just looks at him and
go, Oh, this is actually a long way,
but this one, it's got a huge boner.
Is Dick's getting hard as fuck?
I was playing a guy. That's good guy.
Must be good. Yeah, look, he's paused.
He has to pause. I moved. Oh Shit.
That was a little kid. Right?
He's like not that good fun face.
Look that kid like how old are you?
You live with? Fuck. I
wonder if there's a limit.
I wonder if he gets like 100
tables in his fucking head explodes
certain amount of tables he could
do. Is he just like, like I,
I don't play chess on the
Chinese checkers, but like
when he looks at it, does he,
is it like a math equation almost to him
or is he really thinking in his head or
is it something that he can just
look at the table? I'm go, all right,
I see what's going on here.
You know what I mean? At
that level has played
thousands of chess games,
like many thousands and
knows the possibilities.
His level is, he has played them.
He's also done them himself.
Like I want to try this route and that
is like, it's a map to him for sure.
He's seen the whole thing and goes, I know
how this can go. I'm going to do this.
Yeah,
I agree.
It seems like there's a certain level
that they get where they see things just
completely differently
and then you and I would,
it's almost like gritted out for him.
He sees the possibilities play out.
There's also games where there play
three chess games simultaneously.
It's like a separate board. Have you
ever seen that? Oh, it's, I don't,
I've seen like this much
larger board and like three,
three different sets of pieces are all
going at it at the same time. Yeah.
I don't know all of it. It's
just too much, man. It's not,
not enough time in the world.
I would like to see chess masters
versus how much pussy they get.
Like on a chart, like how great you
have to be like Casper off at its best.
How little pussy was getting
like you can't be getting any,
well we would like to
think they don't get any.
We would like to thank as men who
can't play chess would be like, yeah.
Being gotten any pussy. Yeah. That
would help us. Right? I, yeah,
I would feel better about that.
Yeah.
I don't want him to think that he's way
smarter than me and he gets a lot of
poster.
I think he,
I think a guy though at that level
with what he's doing, his time to,
to indulge in him, his interest
of pussy is not that great. Well,
I think there's probably
such a bad motherfucker too.
He probably can't even talk to regular
people. Right. Like if he, if you were,
if he was gay and he had it,
fuck you with the conversation
you would have with you.
It'd be like Jesus Christ. Yeah. Let
me just shut up and suck it. Yeah.
Try to talking to you, Tom. You don't
know shit. I don't care about football.
I have a hundred games going on right now
in the basement there waiting for him.
He sucked my cock. It's like a, it's
just a biological function, right?
Just I just got an empty this maybe
load right now. Well, you know,
that was the story of Nikola Tesla.
I mean,
Nikola Tesla allegedly destroyed
his sexuality. That was the, uh,
the quote.
And the idea was that he
got so flabbergasted by a
relationship that he was
having, it was so emotionally taxing
decided just kills deck. Really?
Yeah. You shock it. I
don't know. There was,
it's an ambiguous that he used,
that he killed his sexuality.
You don't think guys like Kasparov and
Fischer connected with girls who were
like, you're really good at chess.
Maybe I came back. They're really bad.
That's all you do. All those moves.
Yeah, I'm totally beat him. He,
I think to find that quote
because it's a really weird quote.
Sexual desire. Yeah. He's,
he was a weird guy man.
But the, the other thing about Nikola
Tesla is that he was so fucking smart.
You would have to be
crazy to be that smart.
I mean there's really no way
around it. Yeah. I think everybody,
all these guys fished it. All
those guys were, they were,
what is it like um, savant?
Yeah, they weren't, you know,
they couldn't have regular conversations
with Tesla also had some strange quote
about pulling signals from other worlds
that he was receiving communication from
other worlds and was getting some
ideas from out from other worlds.
He had a really bizarre mind.
But the thing about it is you
can't deny the effectiveness of it.
It's real weird when someone is
an obvious genuine 100% bonafide,
super genius to the point where a guy
like me can't even understand how this guy
could come up with 70 patents.
I mean he had so many fucking patents,
so many different like
light and illumination based
systems designed by Tesla,
dynamic electric machine communicators.
The first patterns issues to
Tesla and the u s he, he just,
he just did a amazing shitty
developed alternating current.
Like before that was just direct car,
you couldn't have like a toaster and lag,
a car plugged into the same port and
he designed it so designed alternating
current.
So that would work with different shit.
Do you think that like the reason like
we are designed so that it doesn't
frustrate us how much smarter
people like that are? Yes. Yeah.
Like what the math thing that
we were talking about, I think,
I think there's a giant spectrum
of human beings, first of all.
And I think that there's a reason why
personalities vary so much and I think
it's part of the whole machine that keeps
society moving. Yeah. It's like that.
There has to be jokers and there have
to be serious people and they have to,
or people that are obsessive about things
and there have to be people who are
lazy.
They just had to be people that accept
shitty jobs and people that want the best
of everything always.
And you have this insatiable desire to
get the most expensive car and the most
expensive wife, if they're almost
like machines pushing entropy,
they're almost like machines pushing
momentum and it's like these various
different variations and personality
from the full spectrum of incredibly lazy
to insanely ambitious.
It's almost like that's an important that
it all mixes together and acts as like
a machine. You know?
I, that's what I think.
I mean it makes sense to me that
everything that we see is natural.
All behaviors natural. Well
that's behavior and wolves
are honeybees or you know,
coyotes, whatever it is,
behavior of animals is natural,
including almost all the behavior
that human beings exhibit including
materialism.
And then it's almost like materialism
is just another way that we can show our
peacock feathers and our domination
outside of actual physical contest and
fighting.
And that we've figured out this
variable where a guy does not have to be
handsome but does not have to be,
have great genetics.
But if he's got a brilliant mind,
like a Bill Gates type character,
he could rise to the top and be like
one of the sexiest catches a woman could
ever hope for you. Let me, supermodels
would love to go out with Bill Gates.
All my goodness it, Bill Gates was
single. Let's just say it. Bill Gates,
and he just decided,
you know what?
I'm 70 it's time to slink Dick and
Bill Gates just went on a Goddamn tear.
If he could get the hottest, most perfect
women and they would be flabbergasted.
They were Bill Gates. Yeah. God, I
can't believe it. Oh yeah. Just below.
How do I want to be yours, honey, baby,
I'm you. I don't care about looks.
It's what's important to
me. Yeah. Awesome. You're so
amazing. You're so kind to me.
She just wants to cuddle with them and
take cock and diamonds and just get
diamonds everyday.
New diamonds and diamonds
here and everything is made
of diamonds or whole house
houses.
Diamonds,
forget to take the pill pretty often
is going to the maybe come in oopsies.
Yeah. Awesome. Insurance
policy load. Yeah. But that's,
that's part of like this
whole evolutionary system.
It's almost like it's,
it's designed that way.
It's designed as being another outlet.
You can get the Laird Hamilton thing
where you just like this beautiful man.
It's gigantic. Fuck. Or you know, it
could be Wazniak, you know, cause, right,
right. I snag a little Chubby guy with
$1 billion in the bank. Sure. You know,
makes them quite attractive. Oh my God,
I'm so into surrogates. Yeah. Yeah.
It's weird.
It's these weird variations of what
makes someone attractive and these weird
variations and personality. It's
sort of push, push, you know,
the whole machine,
the homeless scene of culture.
Materialism also applies to like what,
what your sense of self worth. You know,
people get, you get things for yourself
to make yourself feel, to pump,
pump yourself up, you know? Yeah.
This is an expensive thing. I got it.
And therefore people will associate me
with this thing to Tesla invented x rays.
I'm investigating. Did you really?
Yeah. That's my shit. That's shit.
Tesla may have been the first person in
North America to accidentally capture an
x ray image when he tried to photograph
Mark Twain illuminated by an earlier
type of gas discharge tube.
The Geiser Tube in 1895 the only thing
captured was an image in the image was
the metal locking screw
on the camera lens.
Soon after much of Tesla's early research,
hundreds of invention models, plans,
notes, laboratory ideas, tools,
photographs, valued at $50,000 was lost.
And the Fifth Avenue Laboratory
fire of 18 five, my God laboratory,
Frank Wink, wink. Yeah, they
came in towards that place.
It shows notes,
created x rays out of money.
You probably got gangs many times over
for sure. Yeah, it's incredible. Credible.
Yeah. He had something to do with the
invention of radio waves to Jesus,
man of radio rather. Um, he,
I think he had the first radio controlled
remote controlled car or a boat.
He had a remote controlled boat.
Yeah.
1898 Tesla demonstrated a
remote controlled boat. 1898,
dude, I mean, what the fuck?
And 18 he called it tele automation.
Incredible.
It was in Madison Square Garden.
He demonstrated his electric radio
controlled boat in Madison Square Garden.
That's what a big deal it was.
They got had a remote control
boat and everybody was like gas.
That's so long ago to come up with
that. It is an incredible credible. He,
he invented a lot of shit.
A fucking spaceship to those people.
He was also in love with a pigeon. Really?
Yeah. He was in love with is pigeon.
He liked, had a special relationship
with a pigeon like Iron Mike.
I think it's different. Reincarnated.
Who's iron? Mike Tyson. Tyson. Yeah. No,
I think his relationship with the parents,
the pigeon might've been more romantic.
Oh,
see if pigeon flies away and
a flashlight. Yeah, go clean
your stuff in the pool. Yeah.
He had a lot of weird shit with
pigeons. Really. It's such a, yeah.
To be down for. Yeah. I love that.
Pigeon as a man loves a
woman and she loved me.
As long as I had her, there
was a purpose to my life. Yeah,
that's pretty,
that's spelled out right there.
He became a vegetarian in his later
years, living on only milk, bread,
honey and vegetable juices. What about
bird feed? No bird feed. That's sad.
That's for his first pigeon.
He loves one.
He bought injured pigeons back to his
hotel room to nurse back to health.
So he's basically, it kind of
a crazy guy. Lived in a hotel.
He really couldn't like take care of
himself. It was just a dirty dude.
Got some pigeons. I made a lot
of shit. Brian, you're like,
they had a lot of cool check. Listen,
there's no need to be mean to each other.
All right. This podcast basically
over if you love Tommy Buns,
like I love Tommy Buns and you live
in Toronto. Tough shit sold out.
Last, last I check, there was very
little tickets. It's really, yeah,
a submit during a handful,
but it will be me,
Tommy buns and Brian Cowen Thursday night.
And uh,
I just signed up to do the comedy
and Magic Club next weekend,
the 27th and the 28th.
Big Fun. I love Mike.
Great Guy owns that place.
Most of the beach baby.
And then after that I'm at the Ontario
Improv. Um, I got a lot of shit happening.
People trying to do a lot of stand up.
Now.
I'm really enjoying the shit out of it.
Now that my TV shows done,
I feel a weight is lifted
off my shoulders. A breath
of fresh air under my wings.
Like a butterfly. Nice Tommy
Buttons. Yeah, you can fly
now. I'm fucking excited.
I'm going to, that's going to be awesome.
I'm going to go with Brian next week.
This one that's right to Columbus,
Ohio.
The number one new gay spot on. They're
going to do a geisha pair has landed.
It's going to be fine. We're going to
be a bit Tony Hinchcliffe and Christina
and then Christina and I go
do a bunch of like one night.
Where's your website so they can find
the date? I'm cigarette out outcome.
Tom Segura seg. You are a dot
Cohen everywhere. Nashville,
Birmingham, Charlotte,
Atlanta,
all over the world.
All over the world worldwide.
Um,
the tomorrow podcast, Matt, full Tron,
he'll be in tomorrow, the full charge,
then a Wednesday Kathleen Madigan
and then Thursday we'll see.
You fucks north of the border. All right?
We love the shit out of that and, uh,
we'll see you soon.